what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
oh my god okay so I'm back from c2e2 fun
store you guys are gonna get kicked out
of this fun story
so writer Nick Spencer the guy who's
writing Captain America Steve Rogers and
secret Empire and Captain America Sam
Wilson and a handful of other stories he
had like a one hour signing at the
Marvel booth at c2e2 and so I'm sitting
in line and I'm just like oh my god this
is gonna be so cool to finally meet Nick
Spencer and say hey look man I love what
you're doing with Steve Rogers I think
him being a Hydra agent is a little the
coolest things you know this best come
out of Marvel Comics for quite some time
I get up there and like he signs a theme
for a guy he's like cool man thanks for
coming and he looks up he's like you're
the calmest explain guy and I was like
you're Nick Spencer it was so cool cuz
he knew who I was and I mean II didn't
know my name or anything you'd assume
you as a commis explained guy but that's
good enough for me and I was like wow it
was mind-blowing I got a picture with
Jonathan Hickman those of you guys
who've been following my channel long
enough you guys know Hickman is like my
like like man like I'm a fan boy out for
Jonathan hit but I'm just like god I
love your writing he's one of the
coolest guys ever um I got to meet Jason
Aaron and then of course I got to meet
all you guys on the Rob Court and this
is kind of the crazy thing as a youtuber
whenever I upload videos seeing your
comments is one thing and of course I
look at like the views that videos get
and I realize we'll each one of those is
a person but meeting you in person
changes everything because it's like
this person loves my videos and this
person watches them and it's just it
helps to keep me grounded I think it
helps to remind me that tangible people
out there that I could meet at
conventions love the content that I
upload and so it's just it's really cool
to be able to meet and talk to you guys
and yes the rob court will be getting a
Lantern ring that story's being fleshed
out and the ultimate weekly recap those
you guys don't know myself
Binnie a comic story in Caitlyn at that
sea monster and Dylan in the background
we all work together to upload that
series to get it to you guys we have a
current story out going on where I
killed Benny and I will be getting a
yellow lantern ring and eventually the
Rob core rings so a little bit of a
spoiler there but but we pick up with
secret Empire number zero man out let me
tell you something man I was gels going
over this story man I had to stop
halfway through and catch my breath
because I was just like oh my god it's
so good now there are a couple things
with regards to what's going on in
secret Empire we do have to play a
little bit of catch-up and we're gonna
do
in videos I want to get this out there
because I just love it so much and I was
so excited ah but I'm gonna create a
playlist probably here in the next week
or so and it's just gonna be the secret
Empire playlist so it'll have everything
you need to know in chronological order
so we're gonna go back and we're gonna
cover Avengers stand off we're gonna go
back and we're gonna cover like
Thunderbolts and stuff like that I mean
this it's their videos that a lot of
people probably won't care about because
they're so old but I want to have a mare
just for the sake of continuity right so
because of that it'll give people who
are getting into secret Empire a good
starting place in order to see
everything and know how we got to this
point but of course who the guys who
were new secret Empire is basically
marvel's big summer event that's
supposed to set everything back to right
she's supposed to give us back a lot of
the characters that we knew and loved it
things like that and Marvel Legacy looks
like it's shaping up to be Marvel's
version of DC rebirth so Alyssa Lee it's
gonna be kind of cool in terms of how
it's all how it's all playing yeah but
as this opens up myself a minion over a
comic story actually had a debate about
things this segment really covers Steve
Rogers getting back in contact again
with Kraken of course Crockett as we
know him is basically kind of like the
you know one of the top guys within the
Hydra leadership and that's really the
way Hydra is right like you've got you
know Baron von Strucker who originally
broke off of the Nazis thought the Nazis
were short they were short-sighted they
were like look Hydra can be so much more
because the Nazis were like well we know
we're just gonna take over Europe and
then get rid of anybody who's not what
we consider to be you know the perfect
German Hydra was like we don't need to
kill people if we could conquer the
world through other means so Hydra
entered itself into governments and into
companies and the whole nine yards they
basically you know influence themselves
all throughout the world and even
influence the things that shield were
doing they were basically controlling
shield in a lot of different ways and so
because that were there were attempts by
like the Red Skull really right now in
the events leading up to secret Empire
and all-new all-different marvel while
there were attempts by a few individuals
here and there to basically move Hydra
back in the direction of being like the
Nazis in the end Hydra is not the Nazis
and so because of that a Hydra stance
has always been world domination
not executing people because they're not
the perfect German that was the
nonsensical Nazi stuff very
short-sighted very small-town stuff so
because of that what we end up doing
here is we basically have this weird
scenario unfolding and Steve Rogers or
at least the you know what's what seems
to did seem to take place here is you
sort of put in like this pool and what
happens is he's basically told hey luck
your memories will be modified things
will be changed
someone somewhere
line is going to undo everything and so
the indication seems to be here that
Steve Rogers was a Hydra agent right up
until World War two he was basically
working as a Hydra agent until World War
two then he underwent in you know
underwent this whole experience with a
pool that kind of thing and his memories
were modified so that he was basically
the Captain America that we knew that we
know right now the ones you think of
when you think of Captain America what
ended up happening at least the
indication here seems to be that during
the events of Avengers standoff when his
history was modified by the Cosmic Cube
that instead of actually changing his
history and said his history back to the
way it was supposed to be and so again
it's really kind of a cool situation
here because what it's doing is this
toying with the notion that the Captain
America you think of the guy who's you
know fights on behalf of like freedom
and things like that the good Captain
America that that was basically his mind
being modified his memories were altered
uh the bad Captain America the Hydra
Captain America was the true Steve
Rogers it was just hidden under the
surface in terms of memories that were
replacing it so that's somebody that I
imagine will be very divisive among
Captain America fans but to me that's
why it goes into some great storytelling
because then it begs a question which
ones which is this whole thing of ruse
is it basically Hydra saying hey look
Captain America's legacy is growing
beyond the point that we could control
it so we're going to tell him you know
well here's your real history we're
gonna tell him here's what's really
going on we're effectively gonna dupe
him but he is inherently a good guy
there are a lot of things that are going
on here they're really kind of asking
the question is you genuinely good or is
he genuinely bad but the fact remains
here that this is gonna jumps back up to
the modern day because remember right
now Captain America is basically the
director of shield that's something that
we saw you know during the events of the
oath following the trial of Maria Hill
again we've paid very close attention to
the run of Captain America Steve Rogers
and we have all that stuff covered so
far but with him being the director of
shield the funny thing about this is
people still look at him as Captain
America Steve Rogers they look at him as
a good guy they still don't know he's a
Hydra agent but somebody here will
actually find that out and that's one
it's one of the coolest reactions but
what this also does is it basically
brings a lot of these things to bear the
fact that Baron Zemo has been traveling
around rallying up all these different
super villains to attack the various
superheroes at the same time we had
talked about how within the Marvel
landscape that Steve Rogers had
basically stolen a queen from the
Chitauri and then brought it to earth so
the Chitauri army would constantly
launch invasion attacks
it's earth trying to you know take their
queen back and Steve Rogers use this as
a means to instigate the creation of a
shield around the planet earth that
would keep it protected now of course
that shield was the brainchild of Carol
Danvers and Maria Hill and they were
allowed to basically continue the the
creation of this shield but again all
this really seems to coincide where I
guess to really come to a head in the
zero issue when it's just this massive
series of events all unfolding at the
same time now Vinnie has a really good
question he was like why is it that
every time there's like a major event it
always starts with a major battle well
in truth this is really just kind of
designed to grab our attention and bring
us in that's the greatest thing about
what about and what Nick Spencer does
because so far in his writing he doesn't
do a whole lot of like huge grandiose
battles right like it's been all
character development 100% of character
development there's been little battles
here and there and things like that but
on the whole it's largely been almost
entirely character development and it
works out pretty well the issue with
this is that again the shield as it
exists that is supposed to be protecting
the planet Earth is malfunctioning and
so we basically have Tony start and
reread Williams tending to this now this
raised a couple of continuity issues to
me when I was going through here and I
doubt that it was really like a screw-up
on Nick Spencer's part so much as it may
have been a mistake in terms of the
artistry or could just simply be
designed to be that way but Tony Stark
as we know him is a hologram there's
been nothing to indicate in Marvel
Comics that Tony Stark is back in his
physical body as a human being he's
still basically in AI he's an
interactive you know hologram
interactive computer system that
actually serves to be the mentor of riri
Williams as her AI when she's using her
own Iron Man suit and so because of this
the question is padded Tony Stark get
here was a couple a couple answers that
we can really just kind of make up here
until we get something that really
explains what's going on um the first to
me is that it's basically the AI just
using a suit and it's not that outside
of the realm of possibility the suit is
nothing if just not a massive chunk of
technology and so it's entirely possible
that Tony Stark could use as AI
programming to literally just activate a
suit we already saw him do that in the
riri Williams invincible Iron Man vol 1
like all the different suits were
activated by Tony Stark in a training
session and attacked her we'd seen
another suit hijacked by by Rudy
Williams and brought into a conflict by
Tony Stark and it was an older model
suit but the fact remains we've seen
that happens there's a precedence for
um it could also be that 20 Sark is
actually back and you know this story
takes place following Tony Stark's
return and his return hasn't happened
yet or it could simply just be that dr.
Doom's posing as Iron Man and letting
everybody believe that he's Tony Stark
again there's a lot of questions or a
lot of possibilities that exists here
right now but regardless of which one of
those that we choose we do know that
this seems to be Tony Stark in as in all
of his full faculties and his full
abilities now the cool thing about this
is that we also see some really great
villains historically speaking of Marvel
Comics that are kind of brought in here
now some of them appear for a singular
instance and we don't ever see him again
for example graviton graviton shows up
here here's a guy that could basically
manipulate gravity and he's a really
really interesting villain I believe he
was in the Avengers either either was
the animated movie or the animated show
I can't which one it is but the
Incredible Hulk was the only one who was
able to overcome graviton strength and
graviton is basically a guy who can't
manipulate the gravitational pull around
an object meaning he can make something
infinitely heavy he can increase the
gravitational pull on something so where
the gravitational pull around you is 9.8
meters per second squared where you're
just walking around on the sidewalk on a
regular day graviton could run up on you
and increase the gravitational pull on
you which would increase it's like 50
meters per second squared in which case
you would just flatten out you would you
would die but the fact remains you
understand what it is that he's able to
do and so because of this a lot of
different characters are showing up here
we of course have Luke Cage and what's
more or less his Reformation of the
Mighty Avengers you have cloak and
dagger and and an iron fist and a
handful of others you know it's kind of
cool to see Spider Woman different
things like that but it's really more of
like a kind of run over by Sharon Carter
now remember Sharon Carter was the
longtime love interest turned
second-in-command to Steve Rogers now of
course she was initially offered the
position to be director of shield he
turned it down and Steve took it instead
she said look Captain America's the
greatest of us he should be the one to
be director of shield the other half of
this is that there are people there's
basically Hydra forces gaining you know
gaining ground and continuing to launch
their attack against you know various
military groups across the world so it's
all these different plans of Captain
America coming to fruition all these
different plans of Captain America all
coming together to create what amounts
to a world
I did calamity now outside the planet
Earth it's really like the powerhouses
of Marvel right I mean you got Carol
Danvers you have the guardians of the
galaxy you have the ultimate oh you have
Hyperion you have a handful of people
who are out there all trying to destroy
the Chitauri fleet before it actually
gets to earth so they're really kind of
doing the best they can and and they're
doing pretty well considering the fact
that you know there's so many Chitauri
but the problem is that it's just a
constant wave it's a war of attrition as
soon as they destroy the first wave the
next one comes and as soon as they
destroy that wave the next one comes
it's just over and over and over again
now the cool thing about this is that
this really highlights how effective
Captain America is right like we think
of Captain America and it's like well I
mean in terms of powers he's not that
great he's super strong he's athletic
you know he can run really fast he's you
know a human at the peak of physical
conditioning the true ability of Captain
America is his leadership it's his
ability to walk into a situation SEC I
am now taking control here I'm running
the whole show and be effective at it
and that's what makes him such a such a
prominent character that's why he was
always basically the leader of the
Avengers is because he was very good at
delegating who is best in what situation
given their powers or their strengths or
whatever the case may be and so it's
really a combination of things one he's
speaking directly you know with with
Luke Cage or with those guys out on the
street level in New York trying to take
down the various villains he's dealing
with you know I guess talking to dr.
strange who's trying to come or trying
to take out the same thing he's talking
to Carol Danvers out in space you know
he's he's growling a multitude of forces
together the issue with this is that in
the middle of this conflict
Nick Spencer actually draws on the
original Civil War and this is a great
easter egg right
the original Civil War event kicked off
because the villain Nitro blew up
Stamford Connecticut when he was
ambushed by the new warriors that's
basically what happens here in this
instance we end up having a nitro doing
the exact same thing not sure was like
you know I'm just gonna explode he ends
up blowing up detonating you know in an
area of New York and killing multiple
people in response to this and this
massive loss of life
the US government makes the worst
decision imaginable this is this is the
moment when I had to stop this story
right like I was going through the comic
and I was like oh my god I have to stop
I have to pause because the Secretary of
Defense contacts
Steve Rogers and says are you seeing
what we saw in New York a massive
explosion that took down you know it has
a huge amount of loss of life and a
massive amount of property damage and
see Roger says yes but we're trying to
get things under control the Secretary
of Defense response is it's too much for
us to basically sit alongside and watch
this unfold it's not enough for you to
delegate you have to seize control and
so because of this the Secretary of
Defense says the president's been moved
to a safe bunker I've been told to do
the same thing effective this moment
under the United States shield after
whatever is called we are now giving you
full and total control of the United
States military you are effectively the
only person in control of the United
States you're the top person now
everything's been suspended you are now
the one running the show
they have just let the Fox into the
henhouse and as soon as I as soon as I
saw that I was like no you literally
just gave the keys to the city to a
Hydra agent why would you do that and oh
my god but I think my reaction is a
testament to how well this is written
because this is hilarious because it's
really like like Shawn Carter and it's
Captain America that give us these great
you know these great opposing views of
things right with Steve Rogers being
given absolute control Sharon Carter
says it was only in this moment that we
realized our you know looking back
there's only that we realized this was
the beginning of the end we thought we
had it locked down right like we thought
we had it sorted out now everything is
gonna come crashing down
what is up happening here is Steve
Rogers speaks out directly to the
Avengers and says hey look we knew this
day might come
we knew the day might come when we just
encounter just these overwhelming forces
from a multitude of places for whatever
reason all their attacks just happen to
coincide at the same time but he says
we're going to have to do what we need
to do and so even if it means that we
all end up dying in this fight then left
the universe see the fight that we put
up here and so he says even if it's only
for the very last time Avengers Assemble
now immediately after this happens the
shield kicks up right and the idea of-of
riri Williams and Tony Stark is okay
what's going on why do the shield just
suddenly
now of course through their
investigations with the shield working
it's really them as the only two people
who are doing any poking around because
everybody else is celebrating right with
the shield up it means the threats are
now mitigated it means the Chitauri
threat out there they don't have to
worry about that anymore because that
just hari forces are drones they'll just
keep plowing into the shield and dying
and the shield has more than enough
power to repel the the Chitauri trying
to invade the planet Earth and so
because of that now the only concern is
what's going on inside the earth itself
now the cool thing about this is that we
also get the unity squad right you know
the the basically the Avengers x-men a
group that kind of exists in the same
team and you know it's basically you
know sign absent rogue and a handful of
others but it's the Unity squad and of
course they show up and they're there to
kind of help fight against these
villains and so everything's effectively
like you know coming to an end right
it's like look the villains are all
taking off the unity squads here we have
all these events superheroes here the
earth is saved the Chitauri are
basically held off you know for the most
part things are taken care of now again
the funny thing about sharing Carter's
commentary here as she says we all
allowed ourselves to feel like
everything was better we all allowed
ourselves to feel like the day was saved
it's very similar to the beginning of
Civil War - right like there was that
giant so let's Joe from another
dimension that showed up on earth and
the superheroes won and they were like
yeah the days saved the problem with
this is that this is when Steve Rogers
an access plan and that's what's so
brilliant about this right it's only
when people experience the most crushing
loss that they're easier to conquer that
they're they're at their weakest and
they're easiest point to conquer right
when they're riding high right when
they're at their absolute peak you pull
the rug out from under him and the shock
of falling so far so fast
totally overwhelms them and that's
exactly what Steve Rogers does the
others the reason why this happens is
because of the fact that we end up
having another another shield vessel
show up out of nowhere and they end up
realizing this is a shield vessel that
had previously gone missing because they
believed that it had been taken over by
Hydra now the assumption at the time was
it Hydra had basically killed everybody
on board and that was it instead once
they're bracing for impact
once the vessels really seem to crush
Hydra agents begin busting in and
invading this main Helicarrier and this
is when Sharon Carter begins to hear the
voice of dr. Fausta's and this is when
she begins to realize that dr. fauci's
is basically while the second ship was
originally taken over
and how they're taking over this one I
remember dr. Faust this is a
long-standing villain in Marvel Comics
right I mean he's a guy that basically
uses hypnosis to seize control of other
people but in terms of what Nick Spencer
was doing he established that dr. Faust
is alongside the Oh Baron Zemo Baron
Zemo his father was really just one of
these guys that was one of the
predecessors of Hydra there were the
ones basically kind of running the
scenes pulling the strings about
teaching Steve Rogers to become
everything he would need to know in
order to become the greatest of the
Hydra agents and so this shows us the
eventual plan the eventual role that dr.
Fawcett was supposed to play he would
use his powers of hypnosis or as at
least his ability to him to to hypnotize
people into basically going through and
then making them Hydra agents now again
it's cool that Nick Spencer's drawing on
this right because one of dr. Foster's
most significant moments was when he
effectively hypnotized Aaron Carter back
after the events of the first civil war
in 2006 2007 and had her head her shoot
Steve Rogers killing him in the first
place remember that was the whole death
of Steve Rogers crossbones fired the
distraction shot Sharon Carter fired the
killing blow and so the idea is really
an expense are kind of grabbing some of
these themes and throwing them in and it
works incredibly well it works so well
and that's what's so so crazy about this
and this is when this is when Sharon
Carter learns what's going on
when Hydra initially comes bussy and
Steve Rogers says hold your fire and
they stop they stop shooting now
Sharon Carter's response is oh my god
what have they done to you they must
have tricked you they must have taken
you Steve you have to regain yourself
Steve's response is this is not what you
think it is I'm My Mind's not been taken
over I haven't been tricked I'm not
under their control I am a Hydra agent
and Sharon Carter's response is perfect
panic oh my god like denial anger it's
exactly what we would expect right I
mean she's a person that's closest to
Steve Rogers they were lovers at one
point and even now they're still
extremely close as close as they're ever
going to be and so because of that it's
like the ultimate betrayal the man she
thought she trusted the man she thought
they knew that she thought she knew the
man who was the pillar the moral
backbone of the superhero community is a
bad guy is a villain now the reason why
this is so huge it's for a couple
reasons one the
because of the fact that Sharon Carter
MC waters were so close but to Sharon
starting to realize the gravity of the
situation everything that has transpired
in the superhero community everything
Civil War to the whole idea of the
Avengers unity squad every single act
that Steve Rogers has been involved in
has been for no other reason than to
culminate in this moment him gaining
absolute power and that's the fear of it
all is what happens now because no one
but Sharon Carter knows no superheroes
out there but Sharon Carter knows that
Steve Rogers is a bad guy and then
Steve's like take her away get her out
of here now the other half of this is
that because they're close Steve's like
if anybody harms her there will be hell
to pay
but once she's gone she's out of the
picture Steve's like and let it begin
and the walls come crumbling down the
shield that was set up to keep the
dattari out Carol Danvers calls Maggie
says look we have wounded out here we
need them to get back in Steve Roger
says no you're not coming back here none
of you are coming back here all of you
who are out in space are staying out
there that means the guardians of the
galaxy out in space Hyperion
out in space Carol Danvers The Ultimates
all nine yards the powerhouses are out
in space they're not in the picture and
so it's just like oh my god now at the
same time you do have Ruby Williams and
you do have Iron Man asking the question
okay look if this shield suddenly came
back online
then why and the more they investigate
the more they begin to realize someone
sabotaged it so that it would only come
up at this particular moment so while
they don't know it's Steve Rogers they
do know something's off and so it's
really kind of cool because it seems
like Nick Spencer sort of setting the
stage for these two being the ones that
basically lead the way to the downfall
of Steve Rogers or the very least and
attempt to initiate and way to try to
take Steve down now the other half of
this is Baron Zemo
you know helmet Zima and a villain named
blackout now how does even refers to him
as a guy named Bob as far as I'm aware
blackout is a guy by the name of Marcus
Williams so I'm not really sure what the
whole idea here is with Bob unless this
is hydro Bob in which case that would be
really really weird but the idea here is
that blackouts basically able to draw on
something called dark force dimension
and this is really kind of grabbing into
one of the other aspects of Marvel
Comics there's all different kinds of
dimensions dimensions that are composed
purely of energy that's how Cyclops gets
his optic beam
other dimensions that are just
ridiculous other dimensions that are
home to like a villain named nightmare
who basically just influences and seizes
control of people by manipulating their
nightmares but is also insanely powerful
on the other the dark dimension of
Dormammu there's all different kinds of
dimensions out there the dark force is
basically this massive enveloping force
of energy that black out can use for the
purpose of absorbing things into the
dark force dimension so this is exactly
what he does for the city of New York
now the abilities of a blackout are
shown to be extreme here so because of
the fact that dr. strange with all his
powers cannot protect the city of New
York and so this entire section gets
absorbed directly into the dark force
dimension now these are stages that
Steve Rogers taken stage one eliminate
operation alpha flight eliminate the
satellite out there all the forces that
could potentially pose a legitimate
threat to him due to the amount of power
that they have all those spacefaring
guys who are out there stuck outside the
shield that's stage 1 stage 2 take over
New York City and this is when things
begin to get crazy because then we have
Ironman realizing extremely fast what's
going on and he basically says if you
have or if you you know if you are or
have ever been an Avenger or have ever
done anything with regards to the
superhero community come out here now
this is literally the panic button this
is Iron Man hitting the panic button
sending out an SOS and saying if you are
in any form of fashion a hero respond
right now and come to Washington DC and
the reason why is because this is stage
3 this is Steve Rogers solidifying his
control over the world take out the most
powerful heroes allow the only ones left
on earth the ones who can pose some kind
of a threat but really not much and then
seize control seize absolute power of
the White House and then eventually the
world and so really all we have left or
whatever heroes are on earth I mean
you've got Thor you've got Red Hawk
you've got Scarlet Witch you've got some
pretty powerful characters so it's not
like Nick Spencer mention that he's got
rid of the most powerful characters in
the world but there's still some you
know there's still some legitimate
threats but the most notable ones are
outside earth so again it creates kind
of a really funny situation because now
it seems like it's going to be Iron Man
basically serving the purpose of
operating as is this sort of insurgent I
get leader from the Sergent group
against Steve Rogers now the reason why
this matters is because this feels like
this is what civil war 2 should have
been that's exactly what this feels like
it feels like
the other way around remember in the
first civil war event Tony Stark sided
with the US government and Captain
America formed his own Secret Avengers
and this Captain America is a Hydra
agent seizing control of the world
Tony Stark Iron Man forming his own
secret Avengers team would be an amazing
answer to this and so I really I
wouldn't be surprised if at some point
down the road people were like Civil War
two didn't happen what we actually got
was secret Empire and this is the real
Civil War - okay so we're gonna be a
little bit dangerous here we are going
to we're gonna cover secret empire now I
love love love love love secret Empire I
think it's one of the best written
stories Marvel's had for quite some time
and I really loved the way that it all
comes together because to me it tells
this incredible story about the
superheroes
one of the great things about secret
Empire is it shows how pivotal Captain
America is - like the moral focal point
of all of superheroes on earth not just
the United States but all the
superheroes on earth when you gotta keep
in mind Captain America has led a
multitude of different groups that's
usually been the Avengers but whether
it's like a small group here and there
or whether it's like his Secret Avengers
and whether he fights alongside other
superheroes a lot of people across the
world look to Steve Rogers because of
his leadership capabilities because of
the fact that he refuses to give up he
never gives in but the whole point of
secret empire is to give us a scenario
where he turns the entire tables of
everything that's happened on his head
now of course we have all the lead-up to
secret Empire from Captain America Steve
Rogers we have part of Captain America
Sam Wilson but the comments section for
a lot of those videos just turned into
like racial you know arguments and
bigotry and so for the most part I just
stopped doing those videos so you're
welcome to catch up on those on your own
but the fact remains that with with
Steve Rogers remember his entire history
was basically modified Steve Rogers we
knew that was injected with the Super
Soldier Serum he went on to become
Captain America you know he was frozen
in ice for 20 30 years
he was eventually discovered by the
Avengers thought out and he became the
hero that we all know and love
it wasn't until all-new all-different
marvel that we suddenly had a shield
basically going through and grabbing all
these different fragments of different
cosmic cubes that existed over the years
piecing them all together creating one
cohesive Cosmic Cube that shield decided
to create the the whole concept of
Pleasant Hill and Pleasant Hill was
basically using a cosmic cube to more or
less warp reality and
this sort of idyllic prison that
villains could be kept in with no idea
that they were actually being held in
this altered reality so to speak and so
the result was that when Captain America
Steve Rogers and the other Avengers
learned about what was going on it was a
complete violation of the civil rights
of all the different villains that
existed out there and so they basically
broke in to Pleasant Hill they
essentially brought the whole thing down
you know at the same time there was this
big breakout that was initiated and it
ultimately resulted and everything
shield had done coming to light by way
of Rick Jones of course one of the
Friends of the original Incredible Hulk
Bruce Banner who had basically hacked
everything tip the Avengers off dumped
the information out to the world and it
resulted in shield really kind of
getting a negative reputation or even
worse of a reputation than it had before
but it brought the intimates of Pleasant
Hill to light and it allowed the
Avengers to bring it down but in the
middle of all that we ended up finding
out that this cosmic cube had become
sentient and it's always been that way
you know the cosmic cubes always become
sentient and Marvel Comics in some form
or fashion they end up becoming being
just because of the fact that they're
just pure energy that will eventually
take on an actual form the shaper of
worlds is a cosmic cube Kubik
the original Cosmic Cube but this one
was basically composed of different
fragments over the years and because of
the fact that the Red Skull had created
and used his own cosmic cube somewhere
along one this cube itself when it
became sentient because it was new it
was basically a child and as a child it
recognized that one of its fragments had
been used by the Red Skull somewhere
along the line and so it began to look
at the Red Skull as somewhat of a father
figure and in turn the Red Skull began
to corrupt the sentient Cosmic Cube and
used it to not only restore the youth of
Captain America Steve Rogers but to also
modify his entire history to make him a
Hydra agent and so because of this the
Steve Rogers that exists now an all-new
all-different marvel is a hide range
that's really how all that came to be
now of course again we go more in-depth
into that as we go through our Captain
America Steve Rogers stories but a
secret Empire number zero he basically
made his first strike and everything had
been leading up to that point when he
took out when he killed the Red Skull
when he recruited Baron Zemo to his
cause the whole idea was to bring
everything crashing down now the problem
that writer Nick Spencer ran into was
the idea of the Cosmic Cube itself if
the Cosmic Cube it going by the name
topic is the reason why Captain America
is a Hydra agent that all somebody has
to do is capture her and try to force
her or at least brainwash her into
sending things back to rights and so
what
ended up doing was basically having the
Cosmic Cube more or less reformed and
that eventually just broke it into a
thousand shards broken into pieces all
over the place by the Hydra scientist
Erik Selvig who of course it basically
turned coded against Captain America now
of course again the reason for this was
because of the fact that Erik salad they
could basically grown close to Copic as
a little girl kind of viewing her as a
surrogate daughter of sorts and so the
result is that where Captain America
wanted to keep her prisoner if not just
sort of remove her away from everything
it resulted in Selvig just kind of
dispersing her all across the Marvel
Universe that she could be reformed at
some point along the line and her
sentence would be restored so instead of
just allowing her to be a prisoner she
was kind of killed so to speak that's
basically what happened to her character
and so what this story does is it sets
the stage for tracking down all the
pieces of the Cosmic Cube or at least
that's really what issue number one will
do what this immediate segment of the
story does is show us how the heroes
failed now again with Captain America
launching his first strike this came in
a couple forms rumored Carol Danvers as
Captain Marvel had been working on a
shield that was designed for the purpose
of basically protecting the earth from
exterior threats Steve Rogers after
becoming director of shield fired Carol
Danvers and then kept the shield project
and then turned around and basically
initiated this global shield to keep
Carol Danvers and all these guys out and
the reason why was because of the fact
that remember Captain America Steve
Rogers had taken the queen of the
Chitauri race which exists very similar
to termites or ants and the idea was
that they would constantly keep coming
to try to locate their queen
by keeping the Queen hidden on the
planet Earth is essentially create an
infinite wave of Chitauri forces that
would continue to wear down the
superheroes that were fighting outside
of Earth and trying to keep the wave
from penetrating the earth before the
shield went up the issue was that after
having Carol Danvers and all those super
powerful beings outside earth Captain
America immediately initiated the shield
which kept them out they couldn't get in
and all they were doing was just running
into wave after wave after wave of j't
re forces try to arrive on earth itself
now that begs the question why don't
they just leave like why don't they just
go anywhere else in truth a lot of
that's just for the sake of storytelling
just for the sake of showing us what it
is that they're doing but you know for
whatever reason they don't if for no
other reason than to just kind of keep
the story going but back on earth proper
with the forces of Hydra basically
launching their attack across the United
States specifically in New York and the
capital by taking over the White House
this basically brings in
the superheroes now on the whole this is
basically superheroes versus
supervillains that's really what it is I
mean it was you know initially it was
Hydra going to all these villains of the
saying look we know what shield did to
you guys yes you know I'm technically
the director of shield but we will make
a better life for you we will make a
better world all you have to do is fight
on our behalf and this was designed to
be a ruse and a distraction and the
reason why is because remember when it
comes to the Earth's Mightiest Heroes
when it comes to the Avengers being an
Earth's Mightiest hero doesn't
necessarily mean the most powerful it
means being the Earth's Mightiest hero
in terms of your willingness to keep
going what you stand for and your moral
compass and so the Avengers would just
keep on fighting time and time again and
they wouldn't really worry about the
idea of how powerful they were they
would just try to hold everything a
check but even then there were still
some pretty powerful beings here the new
Red Hulk is here vision Scarlet Witch
Miles Morales spider-man's a holographic
Tony Stark riri Williams the new Iron
Man you know I guess going by the name
Iron Heart Hercules Quicksilver you know
the champions the Avengers the whole
nine yards it's everybody doing the best
they can to stop the forces of Hydra and
the cool thing about this is we get this
really interesting narrative along the
way and it actually comes from Black
Widow which I really feel like Black
Widow is giving some of the best
treatment and storytelling in this story
that she has in quite some time or at
least for the first half of the story
anyway but the fact remains Black Widow
really kind of addresses all this and
saying that you know as a person without
any powers but four digits training in
conflict and has consistently been part
of like shield and the Avengers and the
superhero community overall one of the
issues that the superhero community ran
into was that much like you know the
human body growing a resistance to
various illnesses or various cures the
superhero community began to basically
develop an immunity or resistance to the
idea that they could lose that they had
constantly won against like overwhelming
odds
you know the Skrulls would invade the
planet Earth and the superheroes would
win some villain would try to take over
the entirety of the world or the United
States and the superheroes would win
they always came out on top that
eventually a time came when they never
thought that they could lose they could
do no wrong and that's the cool thing
about this is because it's not like the
heroes are full of hubris right it's not
like you know it's not Casey at the bat
well they throw one ball you know and
Casey just kind of sit there read a
newspaper and they throw another ball
and Casey's goofing around then they
throw the third ball and Casey strikes
out I mean it's not them just kind of
being arrogant or anything along those
lines it's just the idea that there's
this
aspect of their personality that they
fought so many different villains they
just couldn't really consider themselves
to be people who would lose and that
would make sense because think about it
over the course of Marvel Comics
publication history even before the
events of all-new all-different model
the first civil war yeah the super
heroes lost but Captain America died he
created a rallying point and then we got
the events of Dark Reign one of the
darkest eras in the history of the
Marvel Universe when Norman Osborn took
over director of shield the super heroes
came out on top when they exposed Norman
Osborn as a guy that he was the Scrolls
invaded the planet Earth during the
events of secret Empire creating all
these doppelgangers of superheroes and
they came out on top danos wielded the
Infinity Gauntlet the heroes came out on
top you know all these stories all these
events that took place the heroes always
ended up winning yes there were
casualties but they always want and as
this idea of Nick Spencer sort of
turning that on its head and saying but
what would happen if they didn't what
would happen if the heroes didn't win
now the question is how because Captain
America by himself is incapable of
defeating all these different
superheroes he just doesn't have the
power to do so and so what he did is he
turned the heroes against each other and
this is designed to feed off the fallout
from civil war too because remember
civil war ii was carol danvers you know
Captain Marvel going against Tony Stark
but at fragment two the entirety of the
superhero community because it was
basically violating people's right to
his pre-crime it was well they haven't
committed a crime yet but they will
so let's arrest them before they do and
so what ended up happening here is that
people began taking up sides they began
saying no no no no I'm with Ironman or I
am with Carol Danvers whatever the case
may be but because of the fact that this
happened so soon after the events of
Civil War two there was no time for
people to band together there was no
time for them to basically begin making
amends for their own actions put the
past in the past and start moving
forward this was an immediate response
with the Hydra inner circle Captain
America Baron Zemo
Arnim Zola hive Kraken and Madame Hydra
all basically showing up on the scene
the fact that Captain America is a Hydra
agent is a crushing blow to the
superheroes because they now have to
face the fact that the greatest hero
among them is the one that's been
working against them and that's the
craziest thing about this because
remember following the revelation of
following the altering of reality by the
Cosmic Cube and Captain America's past
making him a Hydra agent every single
thing that he did whether it was a story
in Marvel Comics that was removed from
the ongoing events and saw Captain
shaking the hand of old man Logan or
whether it was something that tied
directly into Captain America's own
stories he was always operating at the
background he was always working against
the the superheroes a bit of the Marvel
Universe
and so we always had to keep this in
mind everything was moving towards the
idea of him taking over the country and
that's why civil war ii was such a great
story from the perspective of Captain
America because with Captain America
being thrown into the mix what it
basically revealed was that he was the
one Dean then initiated the entire
series of events he's the one that sent
up the conflict between Carol Danvers
and Ironman he's the one that goaded
them into fighting one another he's the
reason why the entirety of Civil War two
happened in a lot of different ways and
why the superhero community remained
split and so with them facing the fact
that Captain America is the one against
them what we end up having are these
series of events that aren't fully
explained they probably will be you know
as a story goes on but at the moment one
of the first things that happens is Jane
Foster Thor is taken out because
remember Thor is one of the most
powerful characters in the Marvel
Universe with her near invulnerability
with her hammer her super-strength she's
somebody who could easily just become a
one-woman wrecking crew with regards to
like the forces of Hydra just start you
know tearing things apart and so what is
up happening throughout this entire
monologue
Black Widow continues to say things like
we fought because we were right but we
fell because we were wrong and so what
is it happening is Jane Foster's
effectively made intangible by a vision
whose corrupted by the forces of Hydra
The Scarlet Witch is effectively taken
over although we don't really know how
it is that that happened and then
ultimately Captain America is able to
reach down and pick up the hammer of
Thor and that was one of the biggest
moments in the entirety of this story
and the reason why is because of the
fact that people looked at it and they
immediately freaked they were like no no
no it says only people who are worthy
can lift the hammer of Thor Kyle Kinane
Captain America pick it up
well they admitted how it was a Captain
America we pick it up the hammer
enchantment does not say whosoever holds
this hammer if he be a good guy shall
possess the power of Thor is says
whosoever holds this hammer if he be
worthy shall possess the power of Thor
and we know by virtue of the story with
Odin's son they're the reason why he
can't lift his own hammers because he
doesn't believe that he's worthy Odin's
son is worthy to pick up his hammer he
just doesn't believe he is and so with
Jane Foster effectively added the
equation Captain America wrecks
everybody and the superhero community
what's left of the Avengers the whole
nine yards and leaves
without any real moral compass at this
point they're just a broken group and
we'll find out how broken they are in
secret Empire number one okay so getting
into secret Empire this is man this
quickly shaped up to be one of my
absolute favorite stories that really
that I've read in Marvel Comics for
quite some time I absolutely love it but
there are a lot of you guys here who are
new a lot of you guys who probably don't
know about all the controversy that's
kind of surrounding it and so what I
want to do is sort of explain this a
little bit because there are a lot of
people who have been looking around and
asking why are people so upset about
what's going on with secret Empire for a
lot of people it's not really secret
Empire that they're upset about it's the
idea of Marvel as a whole what people
look at with Marvel is they get angry
and they say okay Jane Foster is now for
in Odin's son is just a guy wielding an
enchanted axe riri Williams is now Iron
Man and Tony Stark is just in stasis and
this is a I that's basically running
around everywhere people look at these
changes and they're basically saying I'm
not being given a choice I'm not being
asked do I want to read Thor Odin's son
or Jane Foster Thor I'm being told if
you want to read Thor you're reading
Jane Foster people aren't being asked do
you want to read Bruce Banner Incredible
Hulk or do you want to read Amadeus Cho
incredible hole they're being told if
you're reading Hulk you're reading
Amadeus Cho hole that's the biggest
issue that people have they feel like
they're being forced into a situation
but they don't want to be in and if
people have the option of either reading
something they enjoy or reading
something they don't enjoy don't choose
what they enjoy but if what they enjoy
isn't available
they won't choose anything and they'll
walk away and that's the biggest issue
that that that people are facing with
right now so secret Empire initially
opens up with the most logical thing
which is indoctrinating kids and that's
one of the interesting scenarios here is
because when it comes to taking over any
one particular country is all about
indoctrination it's all about going to
people and saying hey take this as an
absolute fact and do not ask why again
it's one of these things that you kind
of see and that's the purpose of it
being in here is to create relatability
but to also show us how far it can go
because in order for society to be
successful there has to be critical
thinking there have to be people who say
but why though like that that has to
happen that always needs to take place
because someone asking why leave
somebody else to say
well here's the answer and if they give
them an answer that requires critical
thinking then the question becomes well
then how did you arrive at that answer
and then that leads into the
whole investigative process and that
leads into more questions being asked
and it leads to the idea of people just
not accepting something as absolute
truth and actually asking questions
about why things are the way they are
and that's really one of the things that
I enjoyed most about this little segment
is it's basically this notion of you
can't take something as an absolute
truth because what had happened is once
Hydra took over Hydra eliminated all
forms of text that they didn't agree
with that was another aspect of
totalitarian and fascist fascist
policies if you disagree with a book
burn it but in the end they weren't
really just burning a book they were
burning the ideology of critical
thinking they were burning the ideology
of saying I don't agree with this but I
also have to accept that there are
opinions out there different from my own
it's more or less kind of purporting
this idea of anybody who doesn't think
the way that I do is wrong and so again
that's why this is so significant is
because that's effectively what Hydra is
doing hydras we don't really just kind
of coming along and saying okay guys
look like we now run the show which
means that kids read the books that we
tell them to read teachers teach what we
tell them to teach the news reports what
we tell it to report it's very much a
totalitarian regime dissent differing
opinions people who don't see the world
the same way that Hydra does all those
people are out stood either they're
ostracized by society or they're
eliminated in their entirety so again
it's one of these scenarios where it's a
very slippery slope the fact remains
there's actually one of the kids in this
class who reports on an inhuman reports
on rice I think is like the older
brother of one of these kids and
basically saying look I saw him doing
something kind of weird only only for us
to find out that you know this kid's
brother had basically swallowed a
Captain America lunchbox in order to get
it for his younger brother and then was
basically sought after by the by the
cops you know more or less for Hydra
Society now again this is designed to
show us how bad things have gotten
you know just because of the fact that
in this particular scenario Inhumans are
immediately arrested if they haven't
registered themselves and that's kind of
an interesting scenario because again
it's creating this idea of individuals
who effectively interred and it makes a
lot of people uncomfortable because what
some people are sort of forced to do
assuming that they actually choose to
read the story as they're kind of forced
to realize that there are uncomfortable
truths out there but the idea isn't to
ignore uncomfortable truths
the idea is to embrace them and asked
why do they make me uncomfortable in the
first place again really feeding into
this idea of critical thinking feeding
into this idea of maybe I should just
ask why as opposed to just kind of
accepting things as an absolute truth
and so one of the
aspects on this is the idea of the
superhero suit is kind of left out in
space keep in mind when Captain America
initially launched his campaign and
began the process of taking over the
United States the shield that Carol
Danvers had worked on the shield that
was designed to keep threats outside of
Earth was enacted Captain Marvel and a
handful of other people out there who
were you know super-powered beings were
basically forced outside of the shield
now remember the reason why this happens
is because it would not have done earth
any good if they were like hey here's
this shield that can protect our planet
from everything except for like really
powerful people because the really
powerful things that are out there are
the ones that you worry about you
worried about Galactus you worry about
that o's who worry about gladiator in
the Shiar Empire trying to obliterate
the whole of humanity this shield is
designed to keep out some of the most
powerful beings in existence and so
there's really no hope for Carol Danvers
or any of their guys to actually get
back onto earth proper so that means
that Hyperion it means that blue Marvel
it means a Carol Danvers yourself it
means that a lot of these characters who
were out there trying to stem off this
tide of Chitauri forces that are
constantly invading earth or at least
constantly trying to invade earth in
order to get their queen will ultimately
lead to them presumably die in combat
now one of the questions that has to be
asked here and this is one of the things
that kind of stood out to me is that if
this shield is capable of keeping out
some of the most powerful beings in the
world and the Chitauri are a race of
aliens akin to insects without any
insane powers whatsoever then why don't
the forces of Carol Danvers and those
guys just leave go get help somewhere
while the Chitauri forces constantly
just bombard themselves onto the shield
and are inevitably killed each and every
time in truth it's just an expense
they're keeping them there it's just a
way for writer Nick Spencer to say hey
look we're keeping them around we want
them around here presumably for this
greatly huge grand pooh-bah conflict
that takes place at the end of
everything and so from this point what
we do is we actually pick up with a kid
named Rashawn and we actually join the
champion so now one thing to keep in
mind and this is why this is really kind
of cool is because of the fact that this
is designed to show us or at least give
us an indication that the superheroes
are really on the run I mean there's
really no hope now we'll find out how
hopeless a lot of them perceive things
to be here in a little while but at the
moment you know we're this kid and you
know Rishon is basically rescued by the
champion so by Miles Morales and by viv
the daughter of vision and by you know
Amadeus Cho Hulk and so on and so forth
where he's whisked away we actually pick
up in Denver with some giant monster
that's you know wreaking havoc now
this is not anything new and really
we're not even giving the origin of this
monster and we don't have to worry about
it this is one of those things where
mixed Spencer kind of plays it fast and
loose with the old-school marvel style
of storytelling and what I mean by that
is back during the 1960's in the early
1970s back when Marvel was coming out
with a lot of new superheroes you really
didn't see a lot of big crossover
conflict of conflict events like you do
now instead with a way Stanley and a lot
of the earlier earlier writers were
Thomas and you know Jerry Conway and
Steve Englehart the way they used to
write those stories back then is while
they weren't the most lighthearted there
were a lot like harder than they are now
and so you would see you know Captain
America facing off and fighting off
against like the snake monster or you
would see Thor against like the molten
man you know we're something along those
lines but you wouldn't see you like
these great big huge grandiose things
and so it's really kind of hitting at
this idea that there's still various
threats out there the difference is how
they're dealt with when it came to the
traditional landscape of Avengers they
wouldn't normally obliterate these
things sometimes they would if the
monster just couldn't be reasoned with
if it was like a you know very primal
intelligence they couldn't understand
speech patterns or anything like that or
if it was just such a violent being that
there was no way to no way to defeat it
outside of killing it then sure they
would fall to that level but for the
most part it was always like contain
capture and then hold it prisoner in
this instance that doesn't happen
instead the Hydra Avengers jump in and
just kill the thing now one of the
things that I want to address here are
some of the members of the Avengers the
Deadpool is straightforward it's all
about cash when it comes to to superiors
finally know I guess the return of
superior spider-man it's more or less
just the idea of you know being on the
devil's right hand than in its path the
same thing with you know with with
Odin's son now there is a little bit
more to Odin son then we'll actually
find out we'll really get around to
issue number four or five and we'll
actually find out there's a lot going on
with this character that we're not being
made aware of right remember Scarlet
Witch has been corrupted although we
don't we don't know how yet released we
don't know how an issue number one and
number four we find out and we can spoil
this a little bit I mean it's not a
great big huge revelation it's literally
just like a one panel thing that shows
us but with a Scarlet Witch she's
basically been corrupted by a demon
named c'thun and c'thun was the being
they gave her her powers in the first
place or at least I just established a
lot of the abilities that she's
currently capable of the problem with
this was that with the character of
Scarlet Witch it was always this ongoing
battle to keep c'thun at bay
much the same way that Doctor Strange
tries to keep like Dormammu at bay the
issue
that we don't really know how but
somewhere along the line the scarlet
witch's ability to fight off the essence
of C'thun was basically hampered or
eliminated in its entirety and C'thun
has totally taken over the body of
Scarlet Witch so in truth while this is
Scarlet Witch it's not really Wanda
Maximoff controlling her it's C'thun get
thrown out controlling her which this is
actually kind of cool because what it
does is it creates a Redemption element
for Wanda Maximoff herself which could
actually tell some pretty compelling
stories at the same time you know where
these guys are basically rounded up
pretty fast from start where they defeat
this monster pretty fast what we do is
we actually pick up with this pretty
interesting revelation in the sense that
while there is a lot of fascist things
taking place the idea that Inhumans are
rounded up if they refuse to register
there's also the idea that the country
is better off than it was before and
again this kind of creates a little bit
of a loss corollary in the sense that
can a country really be better off under
a totalitarian regime and the answer is
yes it actually can countries are
nothing more than a byproduct of people
who own power and the people who try to
keep that power from corrupting
everything the people versus was super
rich or that's how you want to call it
but the idea here is that with a
singular person or council running the
show restricting freedom from everybody
then the emphasis or the issue doesn't
necessarily become people will have the
free will to like buy homes they can't
afford and things like that instead they
will walk where we tell them to they
will do what we tell them to or at least
a large enough majority will that you
don't really have to worry about it and
then from there it's a matter of now how
do we keep them under control and that
is the genius of this it would've been
very easy for Captain America and his
forces to implement this policy where
they're just like tanks in the streets
every day cops stationed outside
people's houses and they follow them
everywhere they go but they don't do
that instead what they do is they say
what we need is to give people a reason
to want us to stay it's not enough for
us to take over we have to give them a
reason to cheer for us and so why
eliminating monsters by creating
shovel-ready jobs and improving the
employment levels by creating a more
stable economy that's how they keep
people there by creating these peace
accords by bringing a bringing conflict
to an end between the United States and
various other territories that are out
there that's how all that ends up
happening they basically say look we've
made the country almost infinitely
better and so ultimately it all is up
coming down on the shoulders of the
people what are you willing to sacrifice
in order to make the world a better
place are you willing to give up your
freedom to make the country better for
people the answer's no you asking that
question and without a second guess the
answer's no absolutely not did they do
refused to give that up and they're mine
you know into the minds of a lot of
people it's I'd rather live in a free
society that destroys itself using its
own freedom then have a long life in a
totalitarian society because what
happens when that council that does
everything to benefit society as a whole
becomes a council that decides to tear
Society down they become evil they
become corrupted they become crooked
well then suddenly we have no choice we
don't have the ability to do anything
and that's the argument that they make
because while things are down and out in
a free society while they're not
necessarily the greatest thing ever the
freedom that that society has allows
them to make it better that's the
difference is that ultimately it all
comes down on the shoulders of the
people and what they're willing to do
and how they're willing to make things
work in order to make them better I mean
the civil rights movement happened to a
degree with regards to government
regulation in terms of new laws being
passed and so on and so forth but it
wasn't soldiers in the streets marching
on behalf of African Americans and
multiple cultures that were out there
instead it was the American people that
were marching out on the streets it was
the American people making their voices
heard when it comes to you know the
whole idea of like you know Marvel's
shift to bring back a lot of the older
characters that people wanted to see
returned it was a government policy that
made that happen it was people who were
saying I'm not gonna read what you're
putting out until you bring back the
characters and I want to see it's
ultimately the people that make those
things happen and so that's one of the
other benefits of the story is because
it shows us that at the end of the day
it all comes down on the shoulders of
people doing the right thing or doing
what they believe to be right to make
society a better place it ultimately
keeps it better for the long haul so
again it's really kind of a cool
scenario here now one of the other
things that really hits on here is the
idea of what's going on with the x-men
all we're really told here is that
there's there's a sort of treaty between
Hydra and the x-men in the sense of the
x-men are given their own autonomy
they're given their own section of the
country where no one's allowed to affect
them you know it's one of those you stay
away I stay away kind of things and that
makes sense when it comes to like Marvel
Comics her mom's really been given like
the x-men kind of the crap end of the
stick and so it's one way to kind of you
know smooth things over with regards to
the fan base in terms of like okay look
you guys don't want the Inhumans we
won't really give you the Inhumans and
we won't punish the x-men for being the
x-men we're not gonna make them like the
butt of all the heinous experiences of
Hydra and said we'll just have them kind
of off in no-man's land within the realm
of Marvel Comics some of the most
powerful beings that exist on the face
of the planet
our mutants and so I mean if your Hydra
and you're running the show do you
really want somebody who can warp
reality screwing it all up for you do
you really want to piss off a guy who
can transmute matter on the atomic scale
just by looking at it is that really a
guy that you want against you or is that
a guy that you want either neutral or on
your side and so again it just kind of
makes good sense with regards to the to
the role that hydras taking but with
regards to the whole idea of you know
the traditional superheroes themselves
or the Avengers as we normally think of
them what we end up doing is of course
we pick up with race Sean and the
champions once they arrive back at the
old Avengers or I guess the new avengers
headquarters kind of this old abandoned
bunker where Hydra wouldn't really look
for them or anything like that but we
end up finding out that things are
actually pretty bad like things are on
the pretty down-and-out just because of
the fact that Rayshawn actually shows up
alongside the champions who have just
kind of made this grab this kid and just
brought him over but once he says look
you know I have some information that
was handed to me by a guy by the name of
Rick Jones don't really know who he is
but he told me to give it to you guys
because he could win the war The
Avengers sent him off to meet Tony Stark
now the reason why is because of the
fact that remember Rick Jones was the
guy who leaked all the information about
hasn't he'll the scenario where shield
was using a Cosmic Cube to manipulate
the reality around it and trick all the
villains into thinking that they were
kind of living in this idyllic paradise
and so because of the fact that Rick
Jones was basically forced into shield
custody after the event of Pleasant Hill
in Ennio and Lewis serving a prison
sentence he was able to gain access to
all kinds of information especially
after Hydra had taken over shield and
the United States and so what are you
done is he had grabbed all these little
bits and pieces of information
consolidated them into a single thumb
drive gave it to race Shawn and them sit
Rayshawn on his way to go meet the
Avengers and so during his conversation
with Tony Stark it's actually kind of an
interesting scenario because Tony
Stark's usually always the futurists
like the idealist he's always thinking
one step ahead or two steps ahead or 20
steps ahead or something like that
but in this instance Tony Stark has
basically given up now the reason why
this is kind of cool is because there's
always been this sort of antithesis
between Tony Stark and Captain America
they represent yin and yang they're
always opposites and it has been since
Civil War Civil War for Captain America
and Iron Man was the Dark Knight Returns
for Batman and Superman
it was the seminal story that basically
established that they're always going to
bump heads forever they're never going
to agree on anything in an absolute way
and so much like the original age of
Ultron story where
and basically taken over the world and
Captain America had effectively given up
until he come out you know until he came
up with an idea to go find one of Nick
Theory's bunkers Tony Stark's much the
same way he's like look we can't fight
man all we can do is just hide we can
just live from one day to the next do
the best we can and then just call it
quits you know just go on for as long as
we can until Hydra catches us or
something along those lines and so again
it's kind of an interesting scenario
because what it tells us is that while
some people have given up others haven't
and the reason why is because of the
fact that we end up learning that with
this whole scenario of Steve Rogers more
or less being a Hydra agent during a
meeting or I guess a dinner that he has
with Sharon Carter there's still a
little bit of humanity left in him and
that's one of the reasons why this is so
interesting is because when it comes to
Captain America he's not wholly evil
right like he's not inherently evil like
I am like Vlad the Impaler and I'm just
going to like kill everybody or
something like that you know it's
nothing along those lines for him it's
really more about the idea of he
genuinely thinks that he's doing the
right thing he genuinely believes that
he's actually making the making the
country a better place which in a lot of
ways he is - those individuals who were
being you know tortured or executed it's
the whole idea of he's genuinely trying
to make the country a better place and
so because of that what he ends up doing
or at least what he's talking to Sharon
Carter's of course is basically told us
that Rick Jones had been captured
following his leaking of all this
information - to race Shawn which
eventually made its way to the Avengers
and an attempt to demonstrate that he's
still the Steve Rogers that Sharon
Carter knows or at least in the sense
that he still has some shred of humanity
she actually asked him to let Rick Jones
live to basically spare his life because
remember he is basically on in sentence
for execution he's gonna be killed and
so the coolest thing about this actually
comes directly from Rick Jones himself
and the reason why is because he's the
guy who just will not give up
Captain America gives them an option and
says look all you have to do is say hail
Hydra that's all you have to do all you
have to do is just say hail Hydra and
you'll go free now this seems like a
small thing right like it seems like a
tiny little thing like all you have to
do is say hail Hydra but it's the idea
behind it it's everything that it stands
for it's saying hail Hydra means hail
Hydra it's a couple of words the words
in and of themselves don't necessarily
mean anything it's the meaning behind
them that has all the significance if
Rick Jones says hail Hydra that it means
that he's effectively given up that he
said okay look I guess Hydra really has
one but so long
does not say hail Hydra it means that
Hydra can be defeated there's at least
one person out there even if he's
moments away from being killed who still
believes that hydras not right who still
believes that Hydra can fall not only
that because of the fact that a lot of
people are aware that Rick Jones had
basically leaked all this information
out with regarding Pleasant Hill that
he's the one that basically was able to
obtain the information and send it over
to to the Avengers the Avengers
themselves now see him is something of a
martyr and so where he's told all you
have to do is say hail Hydra and you'll
live instead he responds Avengers
Assemble and the reason why this is so
important is because of the fact that
now he's a martyr now he's a he's the
cause now it's if we do this we gotta do
it for Rick Jones and the other people
like him his name will always come up
he's going to be a champion of a rebel
effort in order to overthrow a Hydra
proper so that's why this is so
interesting and so ultimately we pick up
with Madame Hydra herself again the
reason why is because of the fact that
we're actually gonna learn there's a lot
more about her then is initially
depicted here but she was the one that
had come along when Steve Rogers was a
little kid and recruited him into Hydra
in the first place alongside his mom and
so the question are the issue that
Captain America faces right now is on
one hand with regards to Rick Jones he's
doing what needs to be done but on the
other hand Rick Jones stands for
something much larger these little rebel
excursions these little attempts to tear
down Hydra these guerrilla warfare
tactics all stem from the idea that
there are still people out there who
believe that Hydra is wrong that Hydra
can be taken down and so what is up
happening as this inner circle you know
crack and dr. Foster's hive Arnim Zola
these different guys all basically say
the only thing that we can do here is
we've got to crack down even harder
we've got to make things even tougher we
have to show them that if they cross us
that we are going to execute them we're
going to destroy everything they know
and love and so Captain America is kind
of torn here just because of the fact
that if he gives in to Hydra to the
Hydra council and says yes you're right
it makes them look weak but if he
doesn't give in then it makes it look
like he's weak on you know people who
were basically being rebels it's a
no-win situation and so ultimately what
he does is he takes his hand out of the
equation in its entirety
he gives the authority to Madame Hydra
to Eliza to basically go through and
implement the ad that's going to show
that strength of Hydra in the face of
those who would attempt to challenge
hydras leadership and so were the
Avengers all gather outside of Las Vegas
to see what the world's going on Hydra
emerges with their massive
ships and begins leveling the entire
city they destroy the entirety of Las
Vegas Nevada alright so getting into
secret Empire part two got this story
just gets better and better I mean this
story is absolutely phenomenal I feel
like it's one of the best stories
account that's that's really come out
with Captain America in a long time uh
but again you know this this really
picks up with the aftermath of the
destruction of Las Vegas now keep in
mind for the superhero community they've
been holding on by a thread right and
that's the significance of secret Empire
that's the basis behind secret Empire
the secret Empire I imagine on some
level is supposed to be political it's
supposed to be like a reflection of the
modern day politics I don't worry about
that side of it I just want to enjoy
this story for what it is and the idea
of superheroes basically being pushed to
the point that they feel like they just
literally can't win is very indicative
of old man Logan of this just dark
atmosphere this dark future where things
are just grim and nobody can really come
back from it any more specifically in
the realm of New York keep in mind we
saw in the Free Comic Book Day version
and secret Empire number zero that New
York was just kind of sucked into the
dark realm you know so because of that
there's no light here I mean it's just
this this dimension where there's
nothing but darkness and the darkness is
permeated by these monsters that seek
nothing more than to kill anything they
come across and so all these inhabitants
of New York City have just kind of
descended into absolute madness and this
is where things get absolutely beautiful
because we initially pick up with really
just kind of a handful of those
individuals those heroes that were in
New York at the time it was whisked away
so Doctor Strange Iron Fist Luke Cage so
on and so forth and it's really kind of
cool because it gives these minor heroes
a chance to shine I mean as cool as Luke
Cage is as cool as Iron Fist is at the
end of the day they're still pretty low
on the on the totem pole when it comes
to like the hierarchy of popular heroes
in the realm of Marvel Comics honestly
Netflix you know whether people loved it
or hated it Netflix shined a lot of
light on the character of Iron Fist
where previously people didn't even know
who he was and so again it was really
kind of an interesting concept but it
really also shines a lot of light no pun
intended on the character of dagger
because remember dagger has the ability
to create these sort of psychic
hardlight constructs so to speak but
she's basically the only source of light
in this dimension of Darkness the reason
why is because of the fact and that for
the character of Doctor Strange his
efforts are almost all
one trying to get them out of there and
so we really can't exhaust all of his
energies instead dagger serves as the
perfect beacon as a perfect source of
light for anybody who's trying to make
their way throughout this city and but
the issue with this is that were
initially she was able to extend this
power for hours and hours and hours and
for days on end is taking this you know
psychological told her bodies perfectly
fun but the idea of standing at the top
of the Empire State Building and just
emitting herself as a beacon of light
for hours on end is psychologically
taxing and that's one of the great
things about secret empires because it's
more than just superheroes fighting
supervillains as good guys versus bad
guys it's the psychological effect that
this has on heroes being put in such
weird and strange situations not only
that that actually allows the villains
to shine in a way that they normally
never would and the reason why this
happens is because of the fact that we
actually pick up with a church and
there's a handful of criminals that kind
of break into this church just because
of the fact that this church has been
getting resources in the form of
medicine different things along those
lines and where some of these hoodlums
break in with the intention of robbing
this priest a guy suddenly shows up
kills one of the criminals and begins
going on this amazing monologue he
basically says you know why are you here
any ideas well you know it's you know
we're getting what we want we were going
to give you you know your your cut of
the profits and all that kind of good
stuff but then just basically revealed
to be the kingpin and the idea here is
that the kingpin really plays this
incredible role it's almost indicative
of the kingpin from the Netflix
daredevil series which I love Vincent
d'Onofrio's kingpin he was I think he's
really one of the best villains that
Marvel's ever had in the history of
their Marvel Cinematic Universe I think
he's probably the standout villain but
the idea here is it he plays very much
the role that were used to if you're not
familiar with kingpin for you he's
probably just a faux Spider Man a faux
of daredevil and that's really about it
but when riders actually take to task
and ride him as a great villain he is
something to behold he is just
beautifully done in this particular
story and the reason why is because of
the fact that he he basically kills
these criminals and he tells the priest
you're your church is under my
protection now I will make sure that you
want for nothing if you need medicine I
will give you the medicine you need if
you need food I will give you the food
that you need if you need water if you
need any kind of resources I will be
there to give it to you but when
everything comes back to normal when we
get back to the back to the
state of things keep in mind who it was
that kept you alive now this is how
Wilson Fisk works in a lot of different
ways
Wilson Fisk in a lot of instances will
just like strong-arm his way into stuff
right like he'll just show up and just
be like and this is mine now but in some
instances he'll just kind of work his
way in and he'll intertwine himself into
these particular scenarios and then
basically start calling in favors later
on down the line but what this also does
is it creates a measure of loyalty it's
really some people for the you know in
this instance who will look at kingpin
estate well he's not nearly as bad as I
thought he was but he helped to keep us
alive he made sure that we had the
resources that we need
he kept bandits and criminals away from
us I mean we don't really owe him so
much as we respect him in the way that
we're going to make sure that we uphold
our end of the bargain that we treat him
with this measure of respect and so it
really turns into something akin to
affection moreso than like loyalty or
the belief that he somehow owed
something and so because of this we kind
of transition out of this dark realm and
we actually pick up with with Tony Stark
himself now again one of the cool things
about secret Empire is it very much
picks up on the state of the Marvel
Universe at this point in time and
coming out of civil war - regardless of
you know whether you love him or hate
him Tony Stark was just one half of the
argument with Carol Danvers on the
character of Ulysses again I had that
Civil War - video down in the
description we're not gonna go too far
into it Civil War - is not a very good
story but the idea here is that Tony
Stark made his own enemies among the
superhero community but the events of
secret Empire do not distinguish which
side anybody was on it's not like
Captain America said okay I'm taking
sides and we're gonna start splitting
people up so the people who are going to
be you know siding with Tony Stark or
who are gonna be stuck here with Tony
Stark are gonna be the same ones who
supported him during the events of Civil
War - it's not like that when the events
of secret Empire popped off and Captain
America made his move and he started
just checkmate after check mate after
checkmate and shutting down all these
different superhero groups just
eradicating them or imprisoning them or
whatever the case may be
it ultimately meant that he was just
superheroes scattering for the wins and
hiding as best they could and so what it
meant is that at that point following
the events of Civil War - Tony Stark in
a lot of ways was surrounded by enemies
this is also compounded by the fact of
just Tony Stark's history superior Iron
Man where he was just an absolute dick
to everybody his history of alcoholism
his actions during the first Civil War
Tony Stark has consistently made enemies
among the superhero community a lot of
different instances and so because of
that
those enemies really haven't let those
issues go they haven't really walked
away it said yeah you know I mean
bygones be bygones it doesn't really
work that way for a lot of people they
still absolutely hate him and so what he
does is it basically had it calls this
truce Anu says okay look guys I know a
lot of you guys don't believe me I know
you guys a lot of you guys don't really
think that I'm a guy who's trustworthy
that's fine
let's let Rick Jones speak and of course
Rick Jones recorded this message you
know before he had died but the cool
thing about this is that Rick Jones is
positioned as this one guy that
everybody trusts because he was a last
guy to shout Avengers Assemble he was
the one guy who wouldn't give ground who
wouldn't give up who wouldn't walk away
from the idea of what it meant to be a
superhero and so the result of this is
that what Rick Jones basically does is
get us caught up on everything that had
happened so far that you know shield was
messing around with recreating a cosmic
cube the Cosmic Cube which is a fragment
or I guess a combination of different
fragments from other cosmic cubes the
result was that one of these fragments
belong to a cosmic cube that the Red
Skull had previously attained when the
Cosmic Cube was reformed and the whole
Pleasant Hill event kicked off and all
that kind of good stuff and the Avengers
and the media became aware of the fact
that shield was basically tricking the
minds of different villains into
believing that they were in a paradise
when they really weren't when the
assault on Pleasant Hill event took
place and Quebec had basically gone
through and began the process of D aging
Steve Rogers in changing his entire
backstory at the whims of the Red Skull
then ultimately it said all these events
in motion that allowed Captain America
to operate behind the scenes without
anybody ever knowing he was a Hydra
agent in the first place now the kicker
to this is that we're comic had
eventually gone on to join the
Thunderbolts under Bucky Barnes this led
to a direct conflict between Captain
America and Bucky Barnes Captain America
killed Bucky Barnes he also killed the
Red Skull and then in turn Erik Selvig
the guy who was basically the science
head next to Captain America working
alongside of him basically dispersed the
shards of the Cosmic Cube all across the
world just because of the fact that the
idea was that Captain America was gonna
take this cosmic cube and make Hydra a
reality that is to say alter you know
the very fabric of reality itself so
that Hydra was in charge of everything
he was basically gonna speed boost his
way all the way up to the top and so the
result is that with these shards kind of
scattered all throughout the world now
it's a hunt for the shards of the Cosmic
Cube it's almost akin to Dragon Ball Z
and the Dragon Balls you everybody's
hunting for these these shards of the
Cosmic Cube the result is that where
Tony Stark and his forces in the midst
of mustering themselves together in
order to Rhea
often achieve this goal Captain
America's doing the exact same thing
remember Steve Rogers is none too happy
about the idea that he had to display
this extreme show of force by wiping out
Las Vegas but it was necessary for him
to do that or at least for him to order
it done for the very purpose of showing
the fact that he's going to do whatever
it takes in order to make sure that
Hydra stays in control now the other
half of this is remember Baron Zemo is
like his man in the corner I mean this
is his right-hand man Baron Zemo will
basically carry out virtually any task
that Captain America asks him to
and that's why Captain America goes to
Baron Zemo and says I want you to track
down the charge the Cosmic Cube I want
you to leave no stone unturned none do
whatever you have to kill whoever you
have to but do what needs to be done and
get me this shard of the Cosmic Cube now
the other half of this is that we
actually pick up about 24 hours after
all this in Colorado and the reason why
is because of the fact that Natasha
Romanoff it basically raced off for the
intention of both you know grabbing
these shards and at the same time trying
to track down and kill Captain America
the issue with this is that she's
eventually located by the champions
themselves and this is really cool
because the champions basically go to
her and say look you have a level of
training that we couldn't even begin to
comprehend and that's true with the
massager Romanoff she's got no powers
but she does have prodigiously when it
comes to espionage I mean she's really
the world's greatest assassin and so
because of that the champions going to
her is basically saying look we need you
to train us in a way that we've never
been trained before we've been trained
to defend we've been trained to stop
threats what we need is training on how
to kill threats and this again is
designed to show us there's just this
tipping point this point at which
everything just kind of switches then
it's not necessarily the superhero
landscape that we're used to anymore the
things have gotten darker things have
gotten grittier more so than that
things have gotten desperate for the
superhero community and so because of
this and what ends up happening here is
we basically have Natasha Romanoff
simply saying welcome to the red room
that's what we're going to do we're
basically gonna switch over to this idea
that I'm gonna train you in the exact
same way that I was trained so it's
really kind of a cool concept but in the
midst of all this what we do is we
actually switch to this weird location
this weird place which we now know as
the vanishing point but the idea here is
that there's just some chick just kind
of running for her life
you guys will notice the art style is
distinctly different this girls running
for her life right just kind of fleeing
these weird things it looks like members
of the serpent Society or what have you
once they actually descend on her
and they intend to kill her these guys
are all defeated by some unnamed person
but when this person is addressed by
this woman when she asks who are you and
what do you want this man simply answers
by saying my name is Steve Rogers and
I'm just trying to get home
comic book fans members of the robbed
core and people who stumbled across this
video man I left you guys on one heck of
a cliffhanger last week man you should
have seen those comments people were
like no it was hilarious but if he
thought that cliffhanger was bad man
what do you see what we do at the end of
this video man anyway so so secret
Empire alright to me there's two kinds
of comic-book stories there's good comic
book stories ones where you just like
it's kind of cool you know and then
there's like amazing comic book stories
I don't really consider there to be like
that at counter book stories because
everybody's got something that they
enjoy about one story for the most part
like I know people who hated spider-man
Clone Saga and I know people who loved
it so there's no absolute truth when it
comes to story that's why I say there's
good and there's amazing but uh in the
last video when we did secret Empire
number two we had basically run over
this idea that Captain America I guess
you know Hydra Captain America Steve
Rogers was basically consolidating his
power he was you know trying to figure
out how to be an effective leader of
Hydra while dealing with the politics of
it all because there were members of the
Hydra Council who were basically saying
hey look you have to make an example of
the various superheroes out there
there's something you just have to kill
whereas Steve Rogers said look if we
start killing off everybody then in the
general public will turn against us and
that was the beauty of it all that was
the beauty of the whole thing is it was
walking this very tight line Steve
Rogers has always historically been
extremely good when it came to tactics
whatever the case may be he always knew
the right direction to go in order to
effectively win or at least try his best
to win and he was really good at
rallying people to his cause and when he
basically you know his whole pass was
rewritten and he effectively became a
Hydra agent or at least that seemed to
be the case the idea was that when they
came to power they said okay look if
there are things that we can do we can
curb you know what it is that people can
and can't do but we have to give them
the illusion that they stand some
measure of success and that was the
reason why the internet was maintained
even with Captain America as the head of
Hydra and Hydra being this you know
fascist dictatorship that was basically
running the show let that people have
the Internet if the people have the
internet they'll have their own little
groups and their own little
organizations and they'll have their
little you know guerrilla warfare
tactics and they'll be stopped
occasionally but you let them go through
with their plans that won't actually do
anything they can lost uses you know a
little battle tactics and so on and so
forth they can take out a few Hydra
forces here and there but in the end
it's one step
forward two steps back they just don't
know that it's happening that's the goal
give people the illusion that they're
succeeding and they'll keep on fighting
and basically you'll be able to maintain
your own your own Empire so again it's
really genius in terms of how it all
unfolds but what this ends up doing is
this jumps back to the idea of the whole
vanishing point that's really the only
indication we've been given of what this
place is and this is where we left off
on the last video because we have Hydra
Captain America who's basically
dominating the entire United States and
then suddenly we have this place off
somewhere that looks like a fantasy land
where we've got another version of Steve
Rogers we don't know who this Steve
Rogers is we know nothing about this guy
all he knows is he says my name is Steve
Rogers and I'm trying to get back home
now of course this coincided with the
arrival of just some girl we're not
giving this girl's name were not given
you know her relevance her significance
what's important here is that she's
there to basically juxtapose this
version of Steve Rogers with the version
of Steve Rogers that we've seen before
the one that's currently running Hydra
and the reason why is because of the
fact that Captain America as a concept
is not lost on writer Nick Spencer the
whole idea of Captain America is that
he's an ideology he is a perspective
he's a viewpoint he stands for something
greater than just a guy with a shield
dressed in the American flag running
around fighting on the side of freedom
that's the whole nature of this is this
designed to show us that this is
basically the Steve Rogers that we all
know and the reason why we get this is
because this girl simply asked do you
remember how you got here do you know
what's going on do you know what this
place is Steve Rogers response is no he
has no clue what this says the only
thing he recalls are the basics his
military training and that's the only
explanation we need that this is the
Steve Rogers that we for the most part
know and love because remember when the
whole origin of Hydra Captain America
was being rewritten this was basically
removed and instead he was brought up
and he was trained by Hydra and so again
these are two completely different
origins for these different characters
and that's how we differentiate between
the two now at this point again we
basically jump over to the idea of Peter
quill and this is kind of funny because
remember with the Captain America Steve
Rogers I guess with a Hydra Captain
America going through and initiating
this shield that's capable of blocking
out virtually any threat this shield
itself took into account virtually every
force that the earth had ever come
across Galactus these various alien
races so on and so forth and so inmates
senses they
create a shield that would be designed
to withstand those forces of what use
would it be to make a shield to protect
the earth if they didn't take into
account people with almost godlike
levels of power that should be able to
get through it but with Peter quill and
the guardians of the galaxy or at least
Peter quill rocket raccoon and group
going out and trying to basically find
people they can rally to their cause
what this does is it brings in the
perception of earth with regards to the
rest of the universe now again this is
not new the earth has always been viewed
as a place that the other alien races
across the universe absolutely hate that
goes all the way back to the Chris
Claremont era of the x-men back in the
1970s and 1980s it's always been that
way
the earth basically houses these
superheroes some of which have insane
levels of power but the earth never
really takes into account how their
actions affect the rest of the universe
and so again because of this is always
one of these things were the Earth's
battles the Earth's problems ultimately
spill out on to the rest of the universe
and all these other different alien
races either have to play mop-up duty or
they have to try to basically run and
flee for their lives in order to avoid
everything that the earth is screwing up
so again this unfolds exactly as we
would expect when Peter quill basically
says hey look here's everything that's
going on ah Captain America basically
turned out to be a bad guy he seized
control of the United States he created
this giant shield around the earth we
need your help in order to basically try
to find a way to take down this u of
whether it's using your technology or
whatever the case may be and they all
say no and not only do they say no they
all start attacking Peter quill because
again it's their chance to basically
take the earth down to keep it isolated
because that's the nature of this Peter
quill is basically making the argument
and saying hey look this won't stop here
like Hydra Captain America they're gonna
start turning their attention to all of
you now keep in mind for the most part
all of these races have all manner of
technology that could easily be used to
basically destroy Hydra but at the same
time Captain America has some pretty
formidable heroes on his side as the
head of Hydra not all of them are there
because they want to beat but regardless
of their motivations they are fighting
on his side and so again it's really
kind of a cool scenario because it
brings in this question of how far is
Hydra Captain America really willing to
go in order to ensure that he can
basically bring peace to earth and then
eventually the universe now at this
point we switch over to a guy by the
name of Frederick and Frederick is
not very relevant at all Frederik Meijer
is a guy that goes by the name of
boomerang and he's literally like
Captain Boomerang from DC Comics except
a lot less interested what is designed
to be is basically here to show us this
is very much like the old man Logan
story remember in the old man Logan's
story all the earth superheroes died and
villains who would have normally had no
real role in society whatsoever suddenly
found themselves rising up and carving
out these little niches for themselves
where they could have their own little
you know quote-unquote empires Hydra
doesn't really care what goes on on the
ground level
hydras out up in the sky they're up in
the clouds so long as they maintain
their control they don't really care
what happens on the surface and that's
what's going on here with guys like
Frederik Meijer this is a small-time
criminal who managed to basically kind
of wheedle his way into this huge amount
of success just because of the fact that
there's really no superheroes that are
willing to step out and fight anymore
because either they're being rounded up
by Hydra or they're just being killed on
sight and so it gives them this chance
to basically carve out his own little
niche now him meeting with Natasha
Romanoff with Black Widow is actually
designed to orchestrate a meet up
between Black Widow and somebody else
and this person is revealed to be Maria
Hill now something that I want you guys
to notice for a lot of the guys who are
not familiar with Marvel Comics this is
one of those Nick Fury moments if you've
been reading Marvel Comics for a long
time you know that like the original
Nick Fury before he became like you know
the unseen the old-school Nick Fury the
white guy with the eye patch and so on
and so forth he was one of these guys
where he was always like the last man
standing if everything went to pot Nick
Nick Fury had all these bunkers
stationed all around the world and he
would just go there he would gather and
tell he would wait it out he would do
whatever it was that he needed to do
Maria Hill is much the same way Maria
Hill is a character who basically found
her huge claim to fame when she became
director of shield prior to and was
director during the events of Marvel's
original Civil War story everybody hated
her like people hated Maria hill during
civil war people were just like hey man
I wish Maria Hill would die but that was
a testament to how well her character
was written but she basically stayed
director of shield for a little while
after Civil War was over Tony Stark
became director of shield eventually he
was removed Norman Osborn became
director then he was removed and then
Maria Hill took his place and then of
course this led into all-new
all-different marvel with Hydra Captain
America orchestrating things behind the
scenes so that Maria Hill
be ousted and then he would take her
place and then initiate his whole plan
to take over the United States but she's
always been one of these characters is
very Nick Fury esque in terms of how she
functions and how she operates she's
able to use what little Intel she has at
her disposal in order to basically grab
the calendar of Steve Rogers now on the
surface it seems totally irrelevant but
the reason why this is important is
because of the fact we actually jump
over to Steve Rogers while he's speaking
with the members of hydras Council these
members of hydras council represent
different aspects some are in charge of
social media some are in charge of the
military but the idea here is that Steve
Rogers is still on the hunt for the
shards of the cosmic you remember those
were destroyed it's really the only way
to basically fix everything and set
things back to the way they're supposed
to be we end up finding out that one of
the charge resides in Atlantis so that's
why this is all happening is because
with the calendar of Hydra Captain
America effectively the former Avengers
that's what we want to call them
basically know exactly where he's going
to be at any given time during the day
and so they know exactly where he's
going what he's gonna be searching for
the whole nine yards and this is
actually going to allow both teams to
converge and encounter one another
during the next issue which is actually
going to be kind of cool but the other
thing about this is that remember name
where the Submariner is hiding to a
degree he's trying to marshal his forces
while they're going around and capturing
these shards of the Cosmic Cube
Arnim Zola tried to invade Wakanda and
was almost immediately repelled black
panther waged absolutely pandemonium
against them with regards to name with a
submariner while the forces of Baron
Zemo and those guys are trying to get in
there ultimately it's always just
backing up it's backing up it's always
running off hiding whatever the case may
be
because remember Atlantis is very much
this uncharted place of Earth in the
Marvel Universe really only neighbor the
Submariner knows the most about it just
because of the fact that he kept it so
secret and would so often refused to
allow anybody to come down there and so
this of course results in in Hydra
Captain America saying fine if he wants
to run and hide then we'll take away his
places to hide and they just bombard
Atlantis with nothing but just Rockets
and these different weapons and so again
well the question is asked whether or
not they need to follow up with the next
location in quote-unquote of course
Hydra Captain America's response is no I
will take care of this on my own
only for us to find out that this
location is the current residence of
Ultron in all new
Herr marvel so again they're all
basically gonna be meeting it with
Ultron in the next story at this point I
want to kind of backtrack for a second
and I want to pick up with Sam Wilson
because remember Sam Wilson was the
all-new Captain America but following
Steve Rogers rise in the reveal that he
was a Hydra agent Sam wasn't basically
quit plus it was also because of the
fact that people were giving him a hard
time after a while so this is one of
those situations where he just says you
know what I'm effectively done and he
currently operates as a smuggler getting
people out of the United States to
territories that are still considered to
be free but notice this is that he
points out the fact to everybody else he
says hey I don't know if you guys
noticed but no one's out fighting in the
streets there's no revolutionary
fighters anymore people have effectively
given up and so again it's one of these
funny situations where it's like if
people really cared that much about
their freedom they would fight for it to
the bitter end the fact that they're not
fighting for it means they don't care
that much about it and if they don't
care that much about it then their
current situation is what they deserve
to have because they're just rolling
over otherwise they would be fighting
against it people don't really care
about who it is that's running the show
so long as things aren't bad for them
and that's not an unreasonable
expectation it's not an unreasonable
stance so long as it can put food on the
table for their kids so long as people
are being rounded up but it's not them
well then suddenly that it's not a great
big huge deal so again it's one of these
these crazy things worse like people
sort of you know stick their head in the
ground ignoring the situation getting
worse and worse and then one day they're
gonna wake up and just realize that
their life's about as terrible as it's
gonna be because Hydra Captain America
made things a lot worse than they could
have been now following up with Sam
Wilson as he's leading the various you
know members of Tony Stark or I guess
hologram Tony Stark and these other
Avengers revolutionaries dr. Brazil
where Ultron's going to be now again for
the most part not all of them know this
is gonna be the case but what we end up
doing here is we actually jump back to
Frederik Meijer for the last he'll bit
of this story and this is really really
cool because Frederik Meijer the guy who
orchestrated this meeting between Maria
Hill and Natasha Romanoff gets up to go
to the bathroom only to find out that
there's a mine planted against the
window or I guess against the glass the
mind goes off and the question is once
he's set upon by whoever it was a plan
of this mind his question is who are you
what do you want this guy's response is
the best way to end a story ever he says
I could be any number of things
vengeance terrible and Swift I could be
the guy that could bring everything that
you love crashing down around you I'm
the guy who could end your life and
heartbeat I could be your punishment and
then Frank Castle The Punisher says hail
Hydra I told you this is gonna be a
cliffhanger I'll be honest I love seeing
your all's reactions to cliffhangers I
love seeing how you guys react to things
because you all usually freak out
usually like no but if you thought the
cliffhangers that I left you on so far
we're bad wait till we get to the end of
this video because this cliff is nuts so
here's the deal if you're just now
joining us with secret Empire there have
been a couple of things that are
happened so far the long and short of
this is that the Cosmic Cube that was
used to basically alter Steve Rogers
memories to make him into a Hydra agent
to basically alter his past the
fragments have been redistributed and
just split throughout the rest of the
world and no one really knows exactly
where they are at this point it is Tony
Stark's rebel team and Captain America's
Hydra team trying to track down these
fragments now of course they have
different motivations as to why Captain
America wants to track down the
fragments and basically restore the
Cosmic Cube so he can alter all of
reality and basically recreate the
universe in the image of Hydra Tony
Stark wants to go through and use the
Cosmic Cube to basically fix everything
and undo hydras rule so it's pretty
simple in terms of how it unfolds but
what we end up doing here is we again
pick up with the vanishing point now
remember the vanishing point is a story
that we don't know anything about we
have no idea what this is all we know is
that it's just someplace that we just
picked up with at some point along line
but what threw everybody off is that
where the entire run of all-new
all-different marvel basically told us
that Steve Rogers Captain America as we
traditionally think of him had his
history altered to make him a Hydra
agent the vanishing point gave us the
correct Steve Rogers the classic Steve
Rogers and so the idea seems to be
hinting here from Marvel that the Hydra
Captain America is not the real Captain
America now how this consolidates and
how this comes together we don't
entirely know and the reason why this is
so significant and the reason why it
raises more questions is because as he's
making his way through this vanishing
point classic Captain America as we're
going to call him is basically met by
the arrival of a couple of foes now
these foes are not significant it's
Batroc the leaper and a few really some
of his most notable notable enemies over
the course of his publication history
but he suddenly met
with the arrival of Bucky Barnes the
Winter Soldier and Sam Wilson now this
is huge because Bucky Barnes was
basically killed by Captain America
which led to you know a lot of the
vincit are taking place in terms of the
the dropping of the Thunderbolts and and
so on and so forth
Sam Wilson is still alive and so the
question is what version of Sam Wilson
is this all we know is that we now have
these three characters and this is kind
of cool because remember historically
speaking when it comes to Marvel comics
this is the trifecta of the Captain
America landscape you have Steve Rogers
you have his sidekick Falcon and you
have Bucky Barnes all three of these
guys have at some point over the course
of their life
been Captain America that's the uniting
factor between the three of them classic
Steve Rogers classic Captain America was
Captain America for years and years and
years and his thundering outside uh you
know of course Sam Wilson was Captain
America and all-new all-different marvel
and Bucky Barnes became Captain America
following the death of Steve Rogers
after Civil War was over the first civil
war event so all these guys have been
Captain America somewhere over the
course of their life now at this point
we switch over to Natasha Romanoff now
this is not a great big huge thing this
is Black Widow is the small little
segment here but this is basically the
idea that remember Black Widow is a
tried and true assassin spy whatever you
want to call her she's a
jack-of-all-trades and probably one of
the most dangerous people in existence
the issue here is that the champions
team the team of teenage superheroes who
broke away from the traditional Avengers
before Secret Empire started basically
joined forces with Natasha Romanoff for
the purpose of learning how to become as
good as she is the issue with this is
they got into it not knowing what they
were getting into
Natasha Romanoff does not play with any
kind of interrogation or anything like
that if you have information she needs
and you're a bad guy she will torture
you or she will kill you she'll do
whatever she has to do in order to get
that info the champions are not really
used to that remember the Charter of the
champions was instigated under the idea
that they basically wanted to help
people where the Avengers showed up into
cities and the Avengers fought bad guys
and then just walked away and said well
you know the government will clean it up
the champions idea was we have to fight
the bad guys but do we also have to make
sure that people are able to get back up
on their feet if their homes were
destroyed or something along those lines
and so they basically wanted to fulfill
the entire role now what this does is it
basically begins to pick up after the
events of our last
video when we had Captain America's team
and Tony Stark's team trying to track
down the fragments of the Cosmic Cube
and this ultimately leads them to Ultron
now this is kind of a cool thing because
remember this salt really goes back to
the rage of Ultron story and if you're
not familiar with that which we have not
covered it comic story and cover that
rage of Ultron was basically a story
that was out of time
Marvel released it and then didn't tell
us when it happened what they did is
with all-new all-different marvel they
rolled that over and put it in
continuity meaning they actually gave it
a time frame but what rage of ultron
basically established was the idea that
ultron had effectively returned ultron
was back and he created like these robot
versions of the avengers and different
things like that but the idea was that
the story concluded with Hank Pym and
Ultron being merged into the same being
and it made sense because Hank Pym was
the creator of Ultron and the two have
always had this sort of unique situation
a very much father-and-son kind of
relationship with each other but it was
only a matter of time before we saw that
kind of an event take place now
following that Ultron appeared a couple
more times
eventually he showed up in all-new
all-different marvel he fought against
the Avengers unity squad which was
Captain America leading like deadpool
basically a combination of mutants and
Inhumans working together but the idea
was that following that event ultron had
basically just kind of been you know
shot out into space or something along
those lines and then we never really
knew what happened to him what this does
is it picks up following the uncanny
Avengers story and it tells us that at
some point somewhere along the line out
in the middle of Alaska somewhere
pintron as we want to call him basically
just began building this massive city
and creating all these Ultron robots now
this does beg the question what would
have happened if he launched an attack
against the superheroes in truth he
probably would have been unsuccessful
Captain America would have been banking
on that or at the very least he would
have been prepared for that because
Ultron has been an enemy of the Avengers
for so long he would have just kind of
adapted to his own schemes and
eventually defeated Ultron but the idea
here is that Pym Tron's just kind of
waiting in the background and that's
kind of a cool scenario here because
when they initially show up and Iron
Man's team ends up fighting Captain
America's Team Ultron steps in and
basically makes them all stop now it's
kind of a funny scenario because we end
up getting some pretty interesting
debates and also answers to some
questions that we've had most notably
what's going on with the Scarlet Witch
but one of the cool things about the
Scarlet Witch is character historically
speaking is that her mom
was always successful in keeping c'thun
at bake-a-thon was just like this wildly
powerful demon that always wanted to
latch on to you and use the power of
Wanda Maximoff but the idea was that he
was never really able to seize total
control of her now of course in this
circumstance by some means that's never
really explained to us
c'thun was able to take over Scarlet
Witch in ur entirety now whether this
was because of the fact this Scarlet
Witch had a psychotic break
when Captain America first launched his
strike whether it was because of the
fact that somebody messed with her mind
we don't really know all we know is that
the demon C'thun has taken over the
Scarlet Witch and that's why Wanda
Maximoff ended up siding with Captain
America the cool thing about this is
that Hank Pym begins to sort of address
these various issues that the teams have
and essentially saying they both believe
they're right they both believe they're
coming out on top of this they both
believe they're doing the right thing
but the question is who is actually
right here is a Captain America as a
Hydra agent who believes that he's
basically going to save the world by
effectively eradicating all the
superheroes in existence and if it goes
on long enough Hydra Captain America
will basically be ruling a cinder but at
the same time the superheroes really
kind of brought this on themselves and
that's the point that Hank Pym makes he
says look you guys have been fighting
forever you guys have been fighting for
so long the infighting it's always been
there it's always been a thing the only
difference here is that enemies came
fast and loose and so you always had
time to basically put your differences
aside and focus on those bad guys but
now you didn't have that opportunity now
one of the guys shows up and basically
proclaims themselves as being a villain
and all your chickens are coming home to
roost now the other cool thing about
this is that Tony Stark begins to goad
Hank Pym and this really hits to the
nature of his character because what he
basically ends up saying here is that
Hank Pym suffers from this constant
inferiority complex and he always did
that was the nature of his character he
stood alongside titans of the industry
like Tony Stark and his Iron Man armor
you had Thor who was basically a God who
had the Incredible Hulk who was a man
among gods
Captain America who everybody looked up
to there were always these superheroes
that everybody idolized or had some
insane amount of power for whatever
reason and then you had Hank Pym who
could shrink or grow and that was it
because of that it always instilled this
inferiority complex this combined with
the fact that Hank Pym created Ultron
and the fact that Hank Pym hit his wife
Tony Stark begins bringing all of the
which in turn leads Hank him to
basically lash out now of course in this
moment this basically allows a sort of
Ultron and Hank Pym personalities to
negotiate for lack of a better words
which allows Hank Pym to essentially
retake his mantle to kind of get back to
being normal more or less but what is up
happening here is that when he sends
everybody along their way and when he
ends up speaking with Captain America
one of the cool things that happens here
as he addresses the nature of the end
result of what will happen remember with
the character of Ultron while Captain
America could likely defeat him it would
be a long and arduous journey and even
then I may very well have been kind of
overshooting it a little bit when I say
the Captain America could defeat Ultron
because that brings another question
well what happened to the age of Ultron
event so with regards to Captain America
and with regards to Ultron what he
basically says is even if the Ultron
personality wanted to conquer everything
it wouldn't be who him to do that it
would actually make the most sense to
let them destroy each other this is
really cool because what this does is it
hits home at a quote that came from a
movie called the sum of all fears when
it had this guy who is basically a Nazi
and he was trying to find a way to take
out the United States and Russia and one
of the things that he said was that
Adolf Hitler was stupid back during the
events of World War two he said you
don't fight the United States and Russia
that's crazy that's suicide what you do
is you get the United States and Russia
to fight each other and destroy each
other and that's the beauty of Ultron's
ultimate goal here why fight Captain
America and Tony Stark at the same time
why fight their enemies at the same time
they're gonna fight until they're all
dead so why not just let them kill each
other and then conquer what's left
Napoleon Bonaparte did the exact same
thing I mean historically speaking when
it comes to any successful Conqueror
dictator Emperor whatever the case may
be they all practice some pretty key key
themes that are for the most part unique
Napoleon Bonaparte would go into
countries start civil wars wait until
their countries were at their weakest
and then conquer them that's how he
expanded his his empire so fast and so
again this really hits at the idea of
Captain America having effectively
obliterated the entirety or at least one
major temple of the Atlantis Kingdom
which resulted of course in May when the
Submariner handing over his piece of the
cosmic team again that was really kind
of like that little thread that was
effectively coming to a close but what
also ends up happening here is we get
this little piece of information we
basically find out that there's someone
on the inside of Iron Man's team there's
basically a mole this also picks up with
the idea of
Hacha Romanov of Black Widow now we
don't see the full extent of what it is
that that she's doing instead what isn't
happening here is that she basically
leads the champions to infiltrate a
Hydra base but also the idea that she
basically picks up with a villain named
Viper
now Viper was a character who got her
claim to fame really is just one of the
notable enemies of various superhero
teams
she wasn't wasn't really like a great
big huge villain but she was one of
those who kind of hung out and magic or
different things like that she had a
pretty cool role when it came to the
death of Wolverine but the idea here is
that it hits home at the notion that not
everybody who sides with Captain America
does so because they genuinely believe
in his cause
Viper is an opportunist she exists to
make money that's her gold if she can
make cash off war profiteering that's
exactly what she will do and what's
happening here is that with Hydra
basically running the show she's running
a narcotics ring and it's kind of cool
because she's doing it under the scene
she's doing it without Captain America
knowing that it's happening and of
course natasha romanoff says hey look
despite Captain America being a Hydra
agent he runs a pretty tight ship and if
he finds out that you're running
narcotics he's gonna kill you he's gonna
use you as an example he's gonna string
you out there and that's gonna be the
end of you and anybody who has the same
ideas that you have and so it's one of
these cool little moments with these
characters we basically see these small
little tidbits coming out about the
things that are going on under the
surface now of course this also
coincides with Tony Stark traveling to
Wakanda what Conda received one of these
shards of the cosmic key when it
dispersed across the planet Earth the
difference here is that one of the Hydra
agents Arnim Zola who's really part of
the inner Council of Hydra has been
trying to infiltrate Wakanda over and
over and over again fighting against
what Conda is not just walking into some
primitive African territory somewhere
and then just taking it and then just
running off you're basically trying to
infiltrate the most technologically
advanced country in the world technology
that's well beyond anything that most of
the planet Earth actually has again what
is up happening here is this hits home
at the history of Iron Man and is kind
of cool this exchange between the two of
them because initially Tony Stark
approaches black panther and says hey
give us your shard of the Cosmic Cube
and we will basically fix everything now
of course black panther response is no
we'll just basically wait it out and of
course Tony Stark's response is well if
you do that a time will come when there
will be nothing for you to wait out when
eventually Captain America's forces
won't be
you're facing against what amounts to a
garrison trying to break into your place
but what happens if the full might of
the Hydra army is brought down on
Wakanda are you really gonna sacrifice
the entirety of your people for the sake
of a Cosmic Cube shard what black
panther basically responds by saying is
that every time Tony Stark tried to do
the right thing he always screwed things
up case in point the original Civil War
event and that's the cool thing about
this Tony Stark was like well hey look
you know if superheroes are fighting
supervillains it's only a matter of time
before the government gets tired of it
and then just makes all superhero
activity illegal in its entirety so I'm
going to basically support the passing
of the superhuman Registration Act and
the hopes that other superheroes will
get on board because it's for the
greater good instead what Tony Stark
dead is instigate one of the greatest
political social and superhero
calamities in the history of Earth and
so again it's one of these cool moments
when it comes to the history of Tony
Stark coming home to roost
and it hits home at the nature that no
one really trusts him now again what
this does is it follows up with the rest
of Tony Stark's team traveling to all
these different locations to these
different places for the purpose of
tracking down what they believe to be
these shards of the Cosmic Cube
explicitly because of the fact that Tony
Stark has this device supposedly that
tells them where the shards are at now
of course what we end up finding out
here is that this thing has been wrong
time and time again they've captured two
shards but they expected to find four or
five more but they haven't and the
question is why well no one really knows
the answer to this all they know is that
the device of Tony Stark isn't working
effectively now at this point we switch
over to probably one of the coolest
moments of the story which is basically
dealing with the x-men remember during
the whole secret Empire event the x-men
are out in Newton which is basically
this new land they've created for
themselves where no one bothers them now
in truth this is done for a couple of
reasons the first is because well you
know the mutant population isn't what it
was before the House of M soap they're
still reeling from the aftermath of that
the other half of this is that when it
comes to the mutant population they're
still pretty powerful mutants by and
large and Marvel Comics are consistently
the most powerful community of
characters in Marvel Comics and you have
a wide array of different abilities
planet-wide telepaths telekinetics you
have people like gambit who can charge
virtually anything he sees and blow it
up you've got cyclops with optic beans
that can slice
in half you've got all these different
characters and all these different
abilities but what Captain America does
here is he actually plays it pretty
smart and it's one of the coolest quotes
he brings Hank McCoy over to where
Thor's hammer is at and the question is
asked why haven't you ever done anything
with it and Captain America's response
is whenever you went to these old
kingdoms and you would have these kings
who would have their swords above their
throne it wasn't to tell people yes I'm
willing to use it it's to tell people
they did use it and they used it to gain
their empire and that's basically what
Captain America does it's an
intimidation technique he basically
brings Hank McCoy over to the hammer of
Thor and says hey look I'm just a man
but with the power for I can bring
Newton to its knees I can literally
destroy everything that you guys love
and then you guys care about and sure
some of you guys might take me out but
in doing so and along the way I will
crush what little hope you have left for
restoring the mutant population to what
it used to be just something to think
about if you decide you don't want a
hand that shard of the Cosmic Cube over
to me that's one of the cool things
about this it's manipulative cunning and
when the question is asked why it is
that Odin's son even sided with Captain
America in the first place what Elden
son does or at least what we get is this
cool explanation Odin's son pays his
allegiance to the hammer of Thor he does
not you know hold any allegiance to
Captain America but the idea is that
Captain America was worthy of lifting
the hammer and so because of that Odin
son effectively looks at this and says
if Captain America is able to wield a
hammer the hammer finds him worthy if
the hammer finds him worthy then Who am
I as unworthy Odin son to stand in his
way now this is cool
because what this does is it seeds doubt
in the mind of Odin's son it seeds doubt
in the mind of the fact that he actually
believes that what Captain America is
doing is right this is really really
important here and the reason why is
because remember Jane Foster is out in
some of the dimensions somewhere it
would not be that far beyond the realm
of possibility that suddenly Odin's son
gets back his ability to wield a hammer
and with the power of Thor rains
Hellfire down on Hydra and the reason
why I say that the reason why I say that
kind of crazy impossible scenario could
be there is because wouldn't we switch
back over to Iron Man we switch back
over to the conversations that he's
having with these other members of his
own team when the questions asked why
isn't your device working the response
is given is it never worked it was never
designed to work what does superheroes
needed
hope they needed to believe that the
thing would actually work and so what he
did is he basically analyzed and used
what little information they got from
Rick Jones at the beginning of the
secret Empire story when Rick Jones said
well here's the best Intel we have on
where the shards may be and basically
began to kind of go through all these
swerves and all these turns to make it
look like the box was leading them to
where it was that they were supposed to
go only for it to be revealed that's not
the case not only that we actually end
up finding out that the person on the
inside at least it seems to be the
person on the inside is mockingbird that
Mockingbird is the Hydra agent spying on
Tony Stark's team so again this is huge
because what it means is that there are
folks all over the place there are
people siding with all manner of
individuals against Tony Stark and what
is up happening is that in this last
little bit of a strike
they basically begin to assault the
fortress of the rebels what last little
vestige of hope they have left is
rapidly beginning to vanish in smoke and
so what we do as we get to this last
little bit of a cliffhanger is we join
with Captain America Bucky Barnes and
Sam Wilson as they're making their way
again through this vanishing point
without us knowing what it really is
they're basically set upon by various
traps that have been set by some unknown
man only for us to find out that these
traps that have been set have been
placed there by the Red Skull who has
every intention of basically continuing
its campaign to kill Captain America but
the true beauty of this story the true
little cliffhanger here is that Captain
America begins to have this conversation
again with Arnim Zola
and what they basically reveal here is
that this massive shield you know this
compound of The Avengers can easily
withstand this assault from Hydra and so
what they need what they need is a force
of unrelenting fury they need a force
that can bust in that can smash the
place to pieces and that can easily
force all the different superheroes out
and so in the last he'll bit of this
discussion we have Captain America walk
into a room and say Bruce Banner it's
good to see you of yet old friend
God so I will be honest secret Empire
just keeps getting better and better I
mean damn this story is so good I've
been telling people ever since like
Captain America was revealed to be a
Hydra agent that this will go down as
one of the greatest runs in the history
of his character it's so different it's
so dynamic I mean I get that there are
those who are just who just don't like
change and that's fun but I think this
is just this is one of the greatest runs
and his character feathers ever been
because the way this ends is insane
now remember for those of you guys who
are joining us for the first time we
kind of have two stories going on
simultaneously right like we have what's
going on out in the real world which is
Hydra Captain America basically trying
to eliminate the last vestiges of the
Avengers which is basically whatever
superheroes manage to evade capture by
Hydra and are basically hiding out in
Nevada alongside Tony Stark trying to
find the remnants of the Cosmic Cube so
they can use it to basically adjust
reality and fix things back to the way
they need to be but then we also have
what's called the vanishing point right
now we don't know anything about the
vanishing point in the next like three
videos we'll know a lot about the
vanishing point and we will know just
how cool it is because dude it's oh my
god dude I really want to talk about
stuff that's gonna happen I really want
to talk about future things but it's
it's really really cool it's it's a
really cool set of events but the
indication here at least in the early
stage is least other you know as we see
it right now the vanishing point seems
to be where heroes go when they die that
really seems to be the case because for
the most part all the characters that
are here are basically dead the only
exception to that was Sam Wilson the
Bucky Barnes was killed in the events
leading up to secret empire Red Skull
was killed in the events leading up to
secret Empire and even this you know
classic as we call on classic Steve
Rogers himself is you know
metaphorically dead and he's been
replaced with Hydra Captain America and
so that's the question that people are
asking and that's the question that I
cannot answer is is Hydra Captain
America even Captain America is all this
going on inside of his own head or is it
a wholly different location is it
actually just another dimension is it
something taking place inside the shards
of the Cosmic Cube these are answers
that we don't have our audience
questions we don't have the answer to in
this video well Hansen
that question later on but the idea here
is that this again focuses on the nature
of the fact that classic Steve Rogers
has basically just been taken prisoner
by Red Skull inside of the inside of the
the vanishing point so again at this
point we switch over to New York City
now remember one of the things that we
had talked about is the idea that New
York City had basically been whisked
away to a place called the dark zone of
the dark realm or whatever you want to
call it but it's basically a place of
total darkness the only source of light
that exists comes in the form of dagger
and she's basically a character that can
kind of create like these hard light
constructs to a degree she's basically
serving as this light atop the Empire
State Building as a way to basically
light the city as best she can
the problem with this is that the use of
her powers takes a physical toll on her
body her entire body goes into creating
life the more she does it the more it
burns her out she's pushing herself to
the point of exhaustion and so because
of this what we end up finding out is
that Stephen strange is basically trying
to find a way to access a spell or
something that will break them out of
this whole dimension now one of the
crazy things that happens here is he
initially addresses a guy called the
librarian and I've never heard of this
guy before I don't really know anything
about him I've poked around online and I
cannot find like a thing on this guy the
librarian he's virtually non-existent
the only way that I can think this
character really makes any kind of sense
is if we were to come to the conclusion
that writer Nick Spencer is basically
drawing on Jonathan Hickman's whole idea
of the sinners market now the sinners
market was a concept that was invented I
believe during Hickman's Avengers and
New Avengers and is basically this this
other dimension of other-dimensional
place where people who can delve in the
mystic arts can go to in order to
basically barter life energy for power
now there's other things that go into it
in terms of just being able to buy like
black-market spells and things like that
that's really what it is is just like a
giant black market when it comes to
mysticism and magic and different things
like that but that's the only sense that
I could make with this guy but again
with Stephen strange what he's basically
trying to do is just find some spells
that will let him break out of this
whole Dark Dimension area now of course
at this point we switch over to one of
the coolest engagements which actually
takes place between kingpin and
daredevil and the reason why is because
with New York City having been whisked
away to this Dark Dimension what is
basically done is this allowed whatever
criminals remain in the city to
basically run rampant so
religious daredevil trying to corral
them all in trying to get everything
back together and basically call it a
day but the other half of this is that
Wilson Fisk never does anything out of
altruism which is to say because it's
the right thing to do
Wilson Fisk always want something in
return and that's really the the
situation that's being brought here when
daredevil jumps in and basically defeats
a handful of Wilson Fisk's men who are
basically taking all these different
medicines and so on and so forth you
know the question is asked why is Wilson
Fisk helping these hospitals and these
these churches and so on and so forth
why is he contributing to that and the
answer to Wilson Fisk is because when
this is all done they will remember
Wilson Fisk has always tried to make New
York City his own Kingdom and in a lot
of ways he has and when we have
daredevil during the whole shadow land
story and then we basically had camp in
picking up the pieces and using what was
left of shadow land to form his own
empire which is kind of cool basically
corralling the hand for those of you
guys who were following the whole
defenders Netflix thing essentially what
seems to be going on with the defenders
is the shadow land story
- daredevil being possessed by like the
beasts of the you know entity that the
hand basically warship that's really the
only difference everything else seems to
be pretty much the exact same I could be
wrong but that basically seems to be the
case that defenders is going to be
shadow land and if it is I am hyped
because that story is so good but the
idea here is that if Wilson Fisk cannot
take over the city of New York through
force then why not take City at the city
of New York by winning the hearts and
minds of people who were there the idea
was that mobsters would basically win
over neighborhoods they would win people
by giving them things so that people
would be less likely to rat out the
actions of the mob when the cops come
walking around and asking questions
what's this guy been doing have you seen
anything suspicious people will say no
everything's been fine as far as I'm
concerned and the cops can't make their
case
Wilson Fisk is walking this exact same
line when the hearts and minds of the
community and the community becomes
yours on a larger scale when the hearts
and minds of New York and New York
becomes yours and so again it says
really cool concept but at this point we
switch back over to red skull and his
whole interrogation with classic Captain
America now again the implication that's
given is that classic Captain America
does not know who the Red Skull is and
that again raises even more questions if
this is classic Captain America
this is red skull how does Kashi captain
America not know who red skull is
they've been fighting for ever and ever
and ever and ever and that's one of the
things that red skull brings up
everything that's transpired up to this
point is because of this war the
superhero community has been fighting
for every man fighting for eons and eons
amongst each other amongst other
villains so on and so forth it's just
been going on and on and on and on and
so when the questions asked is it
possible to escape this place the answer
given by Red Skull is that the only
place to escape is through pain and
through death now of course this
transitions over to the champions now
remember when it came to the champions
they were basically coming out of the
Avengers they looked at the Avengers
team and they said the problem with the
Avengers as they go in they fight
villains and then they give no thought
to what happens afterwards the role of
the champions were just to say basically
these younger teenagers more or less
young avengers effectively was to come
through and say okay not only are we
going to defeat the villains we're gonna
help people rebuild because that's what
superheroes should be doing and the way
in which this transpired was just by
virtue of them you know doing what they
could when they could but when secret
Empire ultimately popped off they
basically ended up you know siding
against Captain America joining Iron Man
which eventually led to them joining
with the ranks of Black Widow who
harbored this idea of just killing
Captain America because of how
villainous he was but what ends up
taking place here is that some of the
members of the champions do not see eye
to eye with what it is that black widows
doing specifically because of the fact
that Black Widow is making some friends
out of some pretty unsavory enemies case
in point Viper
like we talked about in the last video
Viper was a pretty minor villain I mean
she does kind of appear off and on
different things like that but she was a
criminal first and she was a human being
second and the idea was that when secret
Empire basically began to happen when
Captain America instituted his Hydra
regime Viper as part of Hydra began
running her own narcotics ring basically
buying and selling drugs and the result
is that if Captain America were to find
out he would basically have her executed
the problem with this is that with Black
Widow basically going to Viper and
essentially saying I know everything
that you're doing I know what's going on
with Maria Hill doing the exact same
thing and then basically passing this
information on it resulted in the idea
that the champions are now aligned
themselves with effectively a villain
but that's the nature of war right
the enemy of my enemy is my friend it's
not clean it's not clear-cut and that's
the difference between the champions and
characters like Black Widow initially
Black Widow kind of looks at this and
says well it's our fault that we did
this it's our fault you know that we
basically just got in a conflict after
conflict it's our fault that we were
fighting amongst each other so much we
failed to see that the most significant
enemy was the one that we didn't expect
ie Captain America as a Hydra agent
Black Widow looking at this and saying
we brought this on ourselves but Black
Widow also recognizes that the buyers of
war are not absolute there's no good
guys and bad guys there's the guys who
think they're right and then the other
guys who think they're right and they're
both fighting each other but when you're
the champions when you're young when you
see the world through rose-colored
glasses you don't see how it is you see
the world how you would like it to be
and regardless of how you would like the
world to be the world is a certain way
and because of that the champions
haven't quite stepped into the notion of
realizing medicine all it's not just
black and white there's not good guys
and bad guys but there's all different
shades of good guys and there's all
different shades of bad guys black widow
needs to kill Captain America and she'll
ally or herself with whoever she needs
to in order to make that happen
but for the champions right wrong or
otherwise they stick to their guns and
saying no vipers a bad guy
we do not Ally ourselves with bad guys
but again when the questions also raised
as to why they broke this old man out of
a hospital the answer is not given by
black widow now that old guy is actually
gonna be pretty significant he's gonna
be a pretty huge character when it comes
to the forces of Black Widow trying to
topple Captain America I really can't
emphasize how important he is and I'm
kind of curious what you guys think who
do you guys think that old man is this
is a guy that's going to help turn the
tide it's really going to help move
things in a new direction but of course
the idea here is that we switch back
over to Hydra Captain America what we
end up getting is this great monologue
from him which he's always gotta mean
amazing monologues in the story
alongside of what it is that the
Avengers are doing and what we end up
finding out is that the forces of Tony
Stark basically have this massive bunker
they've been operating out of and the
bunker was designed to withstand the
strength of a Thor it was designed to
withstand the abilities of vision to
phase through solid matter it's designed
to withstand virtually everything the
adventures could could account for at
the time that all this is going on
Captain America basically says it was
only ever a matter of time before
something like this happened when it
came to the earth superheroes they
all obsessed with their own individual
goals and that's that really kind of
hits home at the nature of Marvel Super
Heroes marvel superheroes in a lot of
ways are grounded they're very personal
they really focus on the nature of
people
The Avengers aren't necessarily a
tried-and-true superhero team so much as
they are a group of heroes who came
together for like a particular cause but
they all have their own motivations they
all have their own desires the goals
they're trying to achieve Tony Stark is
a futurist he's always looking to the
future you've got Locke Widow who's
carrying all her baggage from the Red
Room you've got Mockingbird who's trying
to prove she's legit you've got
Quicksilver who's just trying to get his
sister back nobody's really looking at
this insane we are a cohesive team
people are looking at this and saying
we're just the last vestiges of what
superheroes used to be and we're just
holding out trying to find the Cosmic
Cube and then maybe we'll win and that's
really yet that's all they have and
Hydra Captain America knows that and
it's the coolest thing because what he
did is he basically turned co2 somebody
he made them into his spine and all it
would take is someone to realize that's
the case and to say someone here is a
spy and then that just becomes
self-destruction because they're so
selfish because they're motivated by
their own desires their own goals at the
end of the day the enemy isn't
necessarily Hydra Captain America the
enemy is their inability to function as
a team to put their problems aside and
focus on a common common enemy for any
real measure of time now of course or
the poking and prodding begins to go
around in terms of the families of the
individual characters who it is us doing
this who it is us doing that what we
also end up finding out is that this
speech that's being given by Captain
America is being given to Bruce Banner
remember Bruce banners back we don't
really know how and the idea here is
that Captain America hits home with the
notion of the reason why it is now the
superheroes always oppose Bruce Banner
because remember it wasn't necessarily
the fact that banner was the Hulk that
led a lot of superheroes to turn against
him even when he was just banner they
didn't necessarily take him seriously
the scientific community didn't
necessarily take him seriously for the
most part when he was a superhero
reaching out to banner for advice or
help on something he was the last guy
they would go to in some cases they
would go to villains before they went to
Bruce Banner it was the total lack of
trust the total disconnect between them
and how they view Banner and the cool
thing about that as Captain America says
the reason why is because you represent
an unquantifiable concept you represent
something
cannot be controlled that cannot be
contained you represent something that
people just cannot fight you are the
quintessential example of absolute pure
and total chaos because that's what the
Hulk is and that's what Captain America
sets The Hulk is just this
uncontrollable thing this force of
nature but the funny thing about this is
that banners response is but you're a
Hydra agent you are not a good guy and
that's the cool thing here is because
it's not like everybody just kind of
looks at this and says yeah what can you
say and then that happens sometimes you
know banner is like the one guy who's
been gone this entire time he's just
kind of resurrected or ever the case
maybe he comes to and suddenly Captain
America's a Hydra agent and hydras taken
over the country and so where banner
initially says okay I can't do this I'm
not going to side with you Captain
America's response is yeah but I wasn't
talking to you Bruce Banner which is
when the Hulk emerges and it is man it
is a sight to behold because like we
said the Hulk is just pure conflict just
pure chaos and that's the crazy thing
because where Scott Lang finally comes
clean and says I'm the spy for Hydra
they have my daughter Cassie they
basically shanghaied me in and said if
you want your daughter to live you're
going to spy on Tony Stark's team when
all this information basically becomes
to the Hulk emerges and masks the caveat
to all this because Tony start to count
it for everything at that point in time
Bruce Banner the Hulk was dead there was
no reason to believe that he was gonna
come back there was no reason to believe
that he would be alive Tony Stark did
not account for this just incalculable
unlimited strength of a force of nature
just coming down on the avengers
headquarters like the wrath of god
nobody expected that to happen but
that's exactly what happens the Hulk
just smashes in and suddenly this entire
bunker is all for naught because all it
takes now are the forces of Hydra
Captain America to come waltzing in
while this is happening the Incredible
Hulk is recalling the events of what it
is it took place during Civil War two
when Hawkeye shot Bruce Banner killed
him with an arrow when Bruce Banner
felt betrayed when Bruce Banner felt
cheated that's why the Hulk is just
raging so much because all this pent-up
emotion it's this feeling of betrayal
this feeling of deception
belief that the superheroes had turned
against him for no real reason
whatsoever at the behest of hero Danvers
all this is coming home to roost and now
the Incredible Hulk is letting it all
out but remember the Incredible Hulk as
he was being resurrected was only ever
temporary again we don't know why we
don't know if magic was used we don't
know if he was like resurrected by
Captain America using to the hand all we
know is that the Incredible Hulk was
brought back for a temporary amount of
time the result of this is that in the
midst of the ensuing chaos in the midst
of the conflict Odin's son shows up but
instead of just quashing any of the
civilians that are trying to get out
instead of just killing every superhero
he comes across he basically allows them
to pass and now remember in the last
video we talked about Odin son's
loyalties Odin son is not loyal to Hydra
Captain America he does not believe that
Hydra Captain America is doing the right
thing he is not okay with what's
happening the loyalties of Odin's son is
to Mjolnir is to the hammer and by his
logic if Captain America can lift the
hammer Captain America is worthy if
Captain America is worthy then Odin's
son should follow him because if he
wasn't worthy if he wasn't righteous he
wouldn't be able to lift the hammer so
again it's a pretty cool scenario it's a
pretty cool set of events now again you
know kind of going through the comments
of the the different videos that we've
talked about with regard to Thor's
hammer I mean there are Sami you know
who are just kind of like no no only
good guys can lift the hammer but like
we talked about before the cause of the
hammer is not predicated on good guys
it's predicated on work that's just the
nature of the hammer that's just how it
works and so again it's one of these
cool things because this ultimately
leads to a fight between Captain America
and Iron Man himself now of course with
the Incredible Hulk just kind of fading
out you know really just more or less
just dying I guess going back to being
dead not really sure were the cases with
him what is up happening is Tony Stark
almost stops Captain America dead in his
tracks and the reason why is because
what he does is he apologizes this is
one of the great things about secret
Empire it draws on everything that's
happened in Marvel Comics in like the
last 10 years maybe even 15 years Tony
Stark even starts talking about the
events of the first Civil War he thought
that he was right he believed that he
was doing the right thing but when the
conflict was done when it was all said
and over you know when the smoke cleared
it wasn't worth it I mean he draws on
the story
the confession for those you guys have
never read it civil war the confession
is basically event via the story is
really like a one-shot that takes place
directly after the events of the death
of Captain America and it's only Tony
Stark and it's only Captain America no
one else's in that story unless they're
in like a flashback or something like
that but what Tony Stark did in that is
he basically confessed and said it
wasn't worth it if I known that Civil
War was going to result in your death I
never would have instigated this
conflict in the first place because
Captain America stands for hope he
stands for the belief in a better
tomorrow and that's kind of the funny
thing about this is because if you look
at Captain America right now he still
does I mean sure Hydra is a fascist
organization right like they're
basically taking over the country and
ruling it in an iron fist but one of the
things that we saw when this story first
kicked off is that there's jobs that are
increasing the stock market's better
people aren't struggling for money for
the most part Society in and of itself
is inherently better so long as you're
the right kind of citizen and that's the
difference here that's the caveat how
much are people willing to sacrifice in
order to make things better is it one of
those things where people are willing to
sit down there say yeah man hydras
running the show and it kind of sucks if
you're that guy but for me it's cool and
now what happens if that guy who says
it's cool Hydra comes knocking on his
door is he still gonna say that is he
still gonna say no everything's fine man
yeah take me away as cool I don't mind
take me off to jail I don't have a
problem with that because society is
better of course not the guy's gonna say
well no no no all right I mean you know
I get that guy don't get me you know I'm
good I'm fine everybody's okay with the
status quo until a status quo shifts and
then the powers that be start coming
after then what we end up finding out is
that the other member is really a lie so
the one that basically brought Steve
Rogers into Hydra when he was a child
and she basically ends up or at least
her forces began picking up some rear
signal emanating from the Avengers
headquarters only for us to find out
that what Tony Stark has effectively
done is activated a tactical nuke and
detonates it basically noose the
entirety of Avengers headquarters and
anybody who was there and so this is
massive because anybody who didn't get
out of the impact of this nuclear bomb
is dead they're gone we don't know who
those people are yet but if they were
there they're up in smoke and so what is
up happening here is Black Widow
listening to the events unfold and
basically comes to the realization that
as far as she's concerned as far as she
knows all the Avengers are dead they're
all gone they just proof like that in a
nuclear explosion if they weren't like
Thor or somebody like that they couldn't
survive it and so in the last little
tale bit of the story
what she does is wake up the champions
with the intention of traveling to Hydra
headquarters and killing Captain America
my dog is probably the dumbest creature
that ever lived I swear to god it's this
dog's dumber than a box of hammers
anyway guys what is up
absolutely love my dog what is going on
guys for those of you guys who don't
know myself comics torreón and Natalie
adds a tickle candy we run a channel
called algebra monster make sure you
guys check that out because we did like
a hide and seek custom game for
overwatch we actually found that mode on
the Internet and it was really really
fun to play it was really cool but
anyway we are back into it with secret
Empire and this is cool because secret
Empire is rapidly proving to be one of
my absolute favorite stories when it
comes to the Captain American landscape
and Marvel Comics at the moment
ironically enough it's like this an old
man Logan or like the only two things
that I'm reading and the Mighty Thor I
took a little bit of a break from the
Mighty Thor during secret Empire because
it's literally just what Jane Foster is
doing while Secret empires going on
which we might cover she just sent some
weird dimension but she came back in the
most recent story so it's still kind of
cool but the idea here is with secret
Empire we are getting into basically the
crescendo which is to say the point at
which we reach the peak and then things
start going down into the conclusion of
the story which you if you are current
with secret Empire is amazing remember
dude that's oh my god it's one of the
coolest moments the most recent one that
just came out issue number nine it
spills the beans on what the vanishing
point is it spills the beans on
everything that's going on with regards
to like what's up with this classic
Captain America character it's kind of
so cool man is so excited anyway so what
we do here we're really into a little
bit of a little bit of a catch-up thing
for this this a little bit of a story
and it works because what this initially
does is it picks up with Alpha Flight
now again Alpha Flight is kind of this
all-encompassing team which is to say
under normal circumstances Alpha Flight
station is just the old Canadian alpha
flight team that was never relevant
which is now operating out of a space
station and still
relevant but they basically serve as
this kind of monitoring force for the
universe remember in Marvel Comics you
have all different kinds of
organizations you have the hand which
contrary to what the defenders say the
hand were never part of Kunlun now the
only thing the defenders got right about
the hand was that they operate behind
the scenes influencing governments
politicians the whole nine yards but the
fact remains here with the different
organizations that exist in Marvel alpha
fly basically took the place of sword
now sword stands for the sentient world
observation and response department and
they basically existed alongside shield
where shield monitored earth sword
monitored space they monitored other
planets races and so on and so forth to
make sure there were no credible threats
to earth that was the normal role they
played the reason why that's important
is because all this really seems to
focus on Carol Danvers in the beginning
which is to say for the first few pages
or so in this little bit of a story
Carol Danvers actually ends up just kind
of speaking in terms of how she views
everything and what's gone down that's
kind of the crazy situation about this
because she's currently speaking to
quasar as quasar exists in the Marvel
Universe now we'll talk about the power
of quasar here in a little bit because I
feel like this will be a pretty cool
discussion point when it comes to her
character just because of the fact that
we kind of have to know a little bit
about quasar in order to understand
everything that's going on there might
be something we discuss in the next
video because quasar is a little more
important in the next video that she is
in this one but the idea is that Carol
Danvers hits back to everything that had
happened
going into all-new all-different marvel
and even before them and that's one of
the reasons why a lot of fans who look
at marvel at the moment they feel a
little disenfranchised in terms of their
attention to Marvel the money they've
paid the readership the whole nine yards
much in the same way the classic DC fans
felt when DC rebooted with the new 52 so
again everything you know all this has
happened before and all of this will
happen again to quote Battlestar
Galactica the idea here is that Carol
Danvers basically says she had always
spent so much time trying to prove
herself as a legitimate hero that
ultimately she got carried away with her
attempts to show that she knew what she
was doing and that's true to a degree
historically speaking up until about
2012 with the first launch of Marvel now
Marvel now 1.0 Carol Danvers was always
a background character she basically had
two major roles in her life the first
one was basically being the vector by
which rogue gained her powers which is
to say rogue latched
Carol Danvers held her for too long and
then basically copied her powers and
that's what made rogue so powerful and
so cool the other half of this was
immortus giving birth to himself by way
of Carol Danvers don't ask why that
story's confusing and it's stupid but
it's one of the things that ended up
happening with her character but up
until 2012 she was never relevant now
the reason why that matters is because
in 2012 because Carol Danvers origin
story basically saw her gaining the
powers of the original Captain Marvel
she had always been living up to his
mantle she always idolized him in 2012
with the original Marvel now Carol
Danvers basically became the new Captain
Marvel because that was just the world
that she needed to take everybody said
hey look you've basically been taking
his role for years and years and years
it's time for you to just take the name
too and so because that it saw her
escapades going into space and it was a
really really beautiful series of
stories with her character in terms of
how she unfolded the problem with this
is that when all-new all-different
marvel kicked off suddenly she was a bad
guy suddenly she was someone who was
just like we have to stop crime before
it happens you know and all this
nonsense and it was really a total 180
from the character that we were used to
but the common thread was that in the
classic stories the way she was written
she was always trying to prove she was a
legitimate hero she was always trying to
prove that hey look I can hold my own
and she could Carol Danvers was a force
to be reckoned with she was not a
pushover
she had energy manipulation powers she
basically had super strength speed
durability she could fly she was like a
female version of Superman who could
shoot energy it was really really cool
but the goal here is she's basically
simply saying everything that's
transpired has happened because of her
during the Civil War two storyline with
the whole idea of Ulysses being able to
see the future she started engineering
circumstances the creation of a shield
to protect the world arresting people
for committing crimes before they happen
different things like that in doing so
she had literally split the superhuman
community in half she had you know
assured in the second Civil War and the
result is that Captain America as a
Hydra agent used that rift in the
superhero community to navigate those
waters to chart that course and catapult
himself to the top by conquering the
United States and allowing Hydra to
reign supreme so in a lot of ways
everything that's happened with secret
Empire is Carol Danvers fault now that
begs the question is it possible things
that could have turned out a different
way well I mean sure it's counter books
you could write in any number of ways
the idea is that in terms of just what
goes on here this most likely would have
happened anyway because the superhero
community in Marvel Comics has always
been fractured the Avengers are always
fighting against some enemies somewhere
but there's always a lot of infighting
as though it was only a matter of time
before something like this happen now
the other half of this is that this also
follows Black Widow because remember
Natasha Romanoff following the events of
the last video that we talked about
where the Incredible Hulk was just
unleashed before his death and he
basically destroyed the entirety of the
Avengers bunker and left him open to
attack from Hydra Black Widow had
basically looked at this and said
Captain America needs to die
but the reason why this is cool is
because this all goes back to Civil War
to remember the great big huge
revelation that came at a Civil War - is
that Miles Morales spider-man is
supposed to kill Captain America and
that's really miles biggest fear keep in
mind those are the guys who were new
Miles Morales was originally spider-man
from the Ultimate Universe which is to
say kind of a more updated contemporary
retelling of superheroes for really the
new generation but when Secret Wars
happen when the collapse of the
multiverse took place Miles Morales was
rolled in to the main Marvel Universe
and then just kind of operated as his
own superhero but during the events of
Civil War two ulysses forced all the
superheroes to see a future where the
united states was an almost complete and
total disarray where the capital
building was just torn all asunder and
amidst it all Miles Morales looked like
he had basically killed Captain America
and so what is up happening here is that
where miles is part of the champions and
miles has come with Black Widow for the
purpose of keeping an eye on her and
trying to aspire from killing Captain
America we also end up finding that he's
basically trapped she literally confined
him within the ship and the reason why
is because she says look Captain America
is gonna die but if he's gonna die he's
gonna die in my hands my hands are gonna
be the ones that are sullied and that's
kind of the cool thing here that's why
Natasha Romanoff is always a little
interesting there's always something
about her that usually takes the reader
by surprise because she is a cold
blooded dyed-in-the-wool
killer that's all she does she's just
one of the best assassins in the world
but for Miles Morales he's still young
he's unsullied by the mark of death
more or less he's unsullied by all these
different things that could basically
turn him into a bad guy
the goal of etosha Romanoff is to make
sure that innocent stay
now this whole idea is basically coming
by way of Captain America on the Capitol
grounds
making a speech and the goal here is to
basically bring in members of Congress
because Congress is still intact and
simply say you guys support what Hydra
is doing don't you now this is kind of
the cool thing because when it comes to
like ruling a country or conquering a
country people will usually only ever
fight back they'll usually only ever
revolt when they feel like they have no
other choice but as long as there's food
on their table as long as there's
clothes on their backs and the backs of
their children as long as there's a roof
over their head and the head of their
children they have no reason to fight
they're not backed up against the wall
and that's what you do in a situation
like this you let people continue to use
the internet you censor it you regulate
it but you let it leak out there's these
dark spots that you can't see these
little sections or you just can't
monitor you can but you let people
believe that you can't they congregate
in those small areas and you weed them
out you set up traps and so ultimately
they're just a dog chasing its tail and
that's the beauty of Captain America's
Hydra he's leading the people to believe
that there is actual progress going on
he's leading the people to believe they
actually have a chance to revolt the
funny thing about this is that that
belief will become absolute truth and
the reason why is because we actually
end up finding out that the old man
who's basically confined in this bed the
old man that we had talked about in
previous videos this old man is
basically housing mosaic now mosaic is
an inhuman who basically has the ability
to possess people he's introduced a
really kind of brought in as a character
that can turn the time and the reason
why is because what Natasha Romanoff
needs is a distraction firing off a shot
into Hydra and killing Captain America
would inevitably you know that would
result in him being gone but she would
end up being captured probably tortured
and then eventually killed the goal is
to take out Captain America and then
become part of the rebuilding process
and so what ends up happening here is
that with mosaic basically jumping from
Hydra agent Hydra agent creating this
sort of turmoil and chaos possessing
this guy of these guys forcing them to
kill each other what it does is it
creates mass pandemonium and mass chaos
and witness chaos happening the goal of
etosha Romanov is to shoot Captain
America the problem with this is that
while she's in the middle of doing that
she suddenly met with the arrival of the
Punisher and that's what make this so
cool because remember the punisher
joined hydra now we didn't initially
know why we weren't really told who
why this was the case all we knew is
that the Punisher allied himself with
Captain America now the explanation
that's given to us is a Captain America
had basically given Punisher and how he
had gone to Frank Castle and said hey
look you've been waging this war against
crime your entire life you've been
killing criminals after they've
committed a crime what if I told you I
would give you an army I would give you
the means to go through and kill every
single criminal that exists what would
you say to that free castles answer is
absolutely yes and that fits perfectly
in line with Frank castle because the
idea is that for Frank Castle all he
wants to do is kill criminals but wait
he's given the given the option to go
through and just achieve his goal in the
extreme why would he turn that down it'd
be absolutely foolish to do so and so
you know at the behest of Captain
America he seeks out Natasha Romanov and
ends up beating the absolute hell out of
her now one thing to keep in mind is
that in a lot of ways this normally
shouldn't happen
Frank Castle is a great fighter he's a
special agent he's been trained in all
kinds of different martial arts and
weapons uses so on and so forth but he's
no Black Widow if it came down to it
under any normal circumstance Black
Widow would beat the hell out of it
that's really not up for debate Frank
Castle couldn't really hold his own
against etosha Romanoff or any man any
measure of taunt this just kind of gives
us a different take on the scenario so
again it's a little bit out of character
for these two guys when etosha Romanoff
ultimately makes her escape and the
reason why is because she notices that
Miles Morales is going to find Captain
America but with her basically bailing
out this begins to bring into fruition
the idea of what it is that Captain
America has been doing and the idea that
Miles Morales is gonna take him out now
keep in mind everybody saw that
prediction of Ulysses including Steve
Rogers himself the difference here is
that when Steve Rogers saw that
prediction he realized that Hydra had
won in that future and so it didn't
matter to him if Miles Morales killed
him because the goal of Hydra would
continue on Hydra would rule the country
and eventually the world and so in his
mind sacrificing his life is a small
price to pay to ensure the dream of
hydras rule continues to live on the
problem with this is that when Natasha
Romanov goes to intervene in an attempt
to stop Miles Morales from potentially
killing Captain America Captain America
breaks her neck with his shield now this
is huge because Natasha Romanoff is one
of the few characters and I'm prudish
unpretty
sure I'm accurate when I say this she's
one of the few characters in Marvel
Comics who's never died there's never
been an instance that I know of where
Natasha Romanoff has been killed not
only that this sets off the attack from
Miles Morales and this is when we start
to get that big picture because remember
when Ulysses originally gave everybody
that glimpse into the future that saw
Miles Morales killing Captain America it
was just that it was tantamount to
taking a photograph and then saying
here's what the future looks like sure
you get that one moment in time but you
don't get the full circumstance you
don't get the full explanation of what
it was that was happening now what we
end up finding out is that this is the
reason why the Captain America was a
Hydra agent had conquered America had
killed Black Widow along with a
multitude of other superheroes and Miles
Morales had just had enough now in this
moment when he's getting ready to kill
Steve Rogers when Steve Rogers is gonna
die he's convinced by the daughter of
hate him and Janet Van Dyne not to do
this and so again that's where the tide
begins to change now again this all goes
back into Ulysses because we didn't know
what happened after we just got this
quick moment Ulysses is like look what's
gonna happen with the superhero
community Miles Morales is gonna kill
Captain America and everybody was like
oh my god and then that's it that's all
we get we didn't get the aftermath it's
entirely possible this was exactly what
was going to happen it's also possible
that because this glimpse was given to
everybody this is what happened that had
that glimpse not happen from Ulysses
they're miles miles would have just
killed Captain America and that would
have been it no muss no fuss Hydra was
basically defeated and that's the kind
of funny thing about this is because
Hydra itself may have engineered its own
destruction and so the result is that
following the attempted you know killing
of Captain America by Miles Morehouse of
course miles is virtually basically
captured and so ultimately we end up
having Sharon Carter brought before
Captain America now remember Sharon
Carter is a character who for quite some
time has not seen herself as an ally of
Steve Rogers once he came out and
declared himself as a Hydra agent she
basically walked away she said I'm not
having anything to do with this but for
the most part she's been kept at him as
a prisoner under the guise the Captain
America can basically bring her over to
his side now cheering Carter is not
particularly important it's really just
an emotional thing because the two of
them were together for quite some time
they were love interest they were meant
to be a thing but in this moment when
Captain America shows weakness Sharon
Carter tries to kill him now this is
huge because this is a throwback to the
original death of
often America's story in the original
event bottle means Civil War and you
know going into Avengers the initiative
I think it was and then eventually the
death of Steve Rogers what we had
learned in that particular story way
back in 2007 2008 2009 some one of those
lines is that the Red Skull had
basically brought in a guy named dr.
Faust as' who had the ability to
hypnotize people into committing acts
Sharon Carter was basically the killing
blow the way that original event
unfolded is that crossbones was a
distraction crossbones fired a shot into
Steve Rogers shoulder Sharon Carter ran
to his aid and then she fired a couple
shots into his stomach in his chest and
that was the end of Captain America
almost immediately after that happened
we learned that dr. Faust this was the
one that had been brainwashing her into
doing that in the first place but again
this all goes back to that idea the
difference here is a Sharon Carter's not
killing him because she's brainwashed
she's trying to kill him because she
just genuinely hates him and so this is
really mixed Spencer saying Captain
America's crossed a line that he can't
come back from if the one person that he
should be able to confide in the most
absolutely tries to kill him because she
despises him he's long gone
there's no way to redeem him and so what
this seems to indicate here is that when
this story ends it will not come by way
of Hydra Captain America waking up and
realizing his mistakes is saying oh my
god what have I done it'll be something
else going on that's something is
explained and a secret Empire issue
number nine I really hope you guys are
current but the idea here we actually
end up picking up with this classic
Captain America and the Red Skull now
the funny thing about this is that Red
Skull tries to kill classic Captain
America but it doesn't look like he's
trying to do this because he's a bad guy
instead classic Captain America gets a
glimpse of this woman who's shrouded in
light and then is able to overcome the
Red Skull but what seemed to have
happened here is Red Skull intended to
kill classic Captain America to save him
but the idea is that classic Captain
America basically overcame the Red Skull
and literally destroyed his own way to
escape the vanishing point and so that's
kind of the crazy thing here is because
the question is one who's this chick and
two what is the vanishing point now of
course back in the aftermath of the
death of Tasha rollin off everybody's
basically struggling with this in a
multitude of different ways really none
more so than Hawkeye because remember
Hawkeye and Black Widow go back why
some ways they both basically appeared
around the same time over the course of
their publication histories they became
good guys and ultimately joined the
Avengers but their histories go hand in
hand to say nothing of the romance
between the two of them so the whole
idea here is that there isn't there's an
effort by the various superhero
community to try to find a way to rally
the problem with this is that the
champions in Miles Morales they've been
captured Natasha Romanov is dead the
bodies of the superhero community just
keep piling up and piling up and piling
up they're fighting a losing war there's
really no way that they can come out on
top here and so ultimately in the myths
of this idea when all hope is
effectively lost Sam Wilson one of my
absolute favorite characters ever
finally returns to the mantle of Captain
America which I am so hyped to see what
happens next this is why I love secret
empire so much I love Sam Wilson Captain
America the god it's one of my absolute
favorite stories one my favorite
favorite roles for his character okay
well I can't necessarily release the
secret empire videos until Friday just
because of the fact that we have to
maintain our schedule it does not keep
me from recording them a week ahead cuz
man do I love this story it's the only
way I know how to work out my excitement
for a secret Empire but in the last
videos what we've talked about so far
because we're approaching the end like
we've got maybe three more videos left
and then secret Empire is done which I'm
gonna be so disappointed in because this
story is so good but what we've talked
about so far is that secret Empire for
the most part has basically played out
in three phases so the first phase dealt
with the idea of Hydra Captain America
basically using civil war to as a way to
implement his own rule in the sense that
the superhero community basically waged
war against one another in the sense
that you had a and inhuman name Ulysses
who could see the future because of the
fact that he could see the future the
superhero community split in half now
over the course of Civil War two there
were times where his visions were a
little off they weren't 100% true but
for the most part they seemed to be now
as a result of these visions Bruce
Banner The Incredible Hulk was killed
different events took place that
ultimately led to this fractured
superhero community in light of that
Captain America as a Hydra agent began
doing things like implementing the
erection of a shield
on the planet that would basically stave
off attacks from all but the most
powerful beings in existence and so
because of this this set the stage for
him to basically conquer the entirety of
the United States with the intention of
turning his sights on to the rest of the
world and then eventually the universe
itself now the way in which he was gonna
conquer the universe came by way of the
Cosmic Cube the problem with this was
that the Cosmic Cube had become sentient
in the form of a girl named Holly and
the idea was that after being taken by
the Red Skull and indoctrinated by
hydras ideologies Sabich at the request
of Red Skull had basically changed the
history of Captain America Steve Rogers
making him a Hydra agent in the first
place the result of this was that one of
Captain America's agents really a guy
named Erik Selvig it was kind of the
scientists working behind the scenes to
help Captain America basically fracture
the Cosmic Cube and so what this did is
it sent the remainder of the superhero
community on a mission to try to capture
what shards were left of the Cosmic Cube
while Captain America tried to do the
same thing the problem with this was
that Captain America was a lot more
influential just because of the fact
that he was using fear and using the
threat of death in order to get people
to hand over their shards of the Cosmic
Cube whereas the Avengers were relying
on diplomacy the result was that we
basically get up to this moment right
now where what's left of the superhero
community is coming together under the
leadership of Captain America Sam Wilson
now the other half of this is that it
deals with a city of New York now the
city of New York had basically
experience being thrown into a place
called the Dark Dimension or the
dimension of Darkness whatever you want
to call it and it was done by a guy by
the name of blackout who quite literally
was able to just kind of enshroud the
entire city of New York
now within New York he also have like
kingpin you had daredevil but really the
only true means for their escape would
come by way of Doctor Strange who would
attempt to use his magic in order to
help them achieve this goal the problem
with this was that it wasn't something
easily done instead it was basically
Doctor Strange using whatever magics he
could to no avail and so the idea here
is that under the speech basically of
Sam Wilson who had vacated his role as
Captain America following Steve Rogers
basically taking over the United States
and then essentially coming back the
world's superheroes basically have a
rallying point and that's the coolest
thing about this is because as Captain
America Captain America was always a
rallying point it was always designed to
be that way and so because of this
dealing with what's left of the
superhero community and Sam Wilson
racing off as best he can try to help
you know quell this threats the various
superheroes facing off against the Hydra
agents and attempt to take their country
back so to speak what this does is it
basically leads into everything that's
been going on with Carol Danvers as well
as the entire Alpha Flight station now
the cool thing about this is that again
this bounces around from location to
location but with dr. strange remember
he's been going to all these different
beings that in some former fashion tie
into magics and mysticism it's one of
the other reasons why New York being
whisked away you know with dark force
energy really helped big Spencer kind of
give himself a way out of the story in
terms of Doctor Strange himself or at
least offer the possibility because
remember just because of the fact that
they're in a different dimension doesn't
mean that dr. strange is any less
powerful than he was before the issue is
can they escape and that's the nature of
a dark a dr. strange going around
grabbing every single spell that he can
muster is an attempt to basically escape
this realm but he's got his books he's
got all these different things but he
just can't pull it off because in truth
the dark force energy is just far too
extreme and he's just not powerful
enough to do it on his own now remember
a lot of this also comes out of the
Jason Aaron Doctor Strange solo series
which is to say during that story we
dealt with the idea that all magic in
existence was basically being destroyed
and that's why all this works it's not
as though Nick Spencer came along and
said we're going to deep Howard dr.
strange strictly for this story instead
it tied directly into his own story
itself in terms of what was going on
with his character with magic basically
being obliterated the source of dr.
Strange's power began to go away now as
the enemies of I can't wear what their
names were but as those enemies who were
destroying magic were basically defeated
and magic began to grow it was like a
tree right like if you go out into a
field and you plant the seedling hoping
it'll grow into a tree and you provide
some water and you allow sunlight to hit
it you're not gonna cut out the next
morning with a full-blown redwood tree
you're gonna have to wait years decades
and order for it to grow to its full
potential now in the case of magic it
wouldn't take hundreds of years for it
to all return but it does take time and
that's the reason why Doctor Strange is
not as powerful as he was before because
the source the the energy he uses of the
magic he uses is
not where it used to be and so a that's
really the nature of his character the
evolution of Doctor Strange in terms of
what it is that he can and can't do the
problem with this is that while they're
trying to cast these spells try as they
might they cannot get out they cannot
get away and so that's the craziest
thing about this at the same time we
also have the guardians of the galaxy
now remember with Alpha Flight with the
forces of of Carol Danvers and Hyperion
and all these beings who could easily
bring Hydra crashing down to the ground
they're all stranded outside the earth
and they're totally incapable of
penetrating the shield now the attempt
to get past it comes by way of Rocket
Raccoon and it's really cool because
Rocket Raccoon literally shows up and
says hey there's this massive bomb that
we have that we literally stole from
another race we're hoping that we can
basically put this bomb inside of the
Alpha Flight station and then crash it
into the shield hoping to blow it up in
the end none of it works the shield is
just as impervious as it ever was and
that's kind of crazy because while all
this is going on there's things like
Doctor Strange cannot get them out of
the dark force dimension Captain America
Sam Wilson in his efforts to basically
take out the shield agents is basically
knocked down into the ocean and is
presumed to be dead it's almost like
this glimpse of success popped up for
their superheroes and almost when they
thought they had a chance to win they
didn't but their one hope comes in the
form of quasar if you're not familiar
with the quasar character it's easily
somebody to write off and that's usually
one of the things that you hear people
who don't know about quasar people who
just kind of read articles or whatever
like whatever it's quasar quasar stupid
it's actually not true and Fantastic
Four Volume one issue number 552 quasar
fought Galactus to a standstill like
Galactus was just literally trying to
kill the Fantastic Four quasar jumped in
and was blocking every single attack
that Galactus threw out which I think
Galactus was in a hundred state which is
when he's as ravenous and more dangerous
than he normally is so in his worst form
quasar held off against Galactus and
that's one of the things about the
character is one of the reasons why
quasar is usually just kind of looked
over and just kind of ignore it when in
reality quasar is insanely powerful now
one other thing to keep in mind is that
quasar was Wendell Vaughn this is a new
quasar but the power is still the exact
same it's a matter of how you use it
they're given these quantum bands which
allows them to tap into an infinite
source of energy and then in turn use
those
however they want to the question is how
far will their imagination take them in
this instance with quasar coming back
it's almost like Galactus showing up and
just ending everything quasar blast the
shield with enough energy to totally
destroy it this is Universal level power
and so that's why it's so cool is
because again this is not Nick Spencer
just beefing up the powers of a
character and saying oh man I need a way
out we're going to amp up the powers of
quasar we're gonna make queries are more
powerful than they'd ever been just for
the sake of achieving this goal that
power has always been there quasars
always been that powerful
it's just how is that power written by
any particular writer and so again with
this scenario with the shield being
totally and completely obliterated by
quasar what it does is it leaves the the
landscape open for those members of
Alpha Flight to come flying back down to
earth which means the Ultimates blue
Marvel one of the most powerful beings
in existence spectrum who can basically
become any form of energy
Hyperion all these characters just come
flooding back into earth and now the
landscape is effectively even the stage
is set for the fall of Hydra and so what
happens is we end up picking up with
Maria Hill now remember if you haven't
been keeping up with secret Empire Maria
hill was very Nick Fury esque in the
sense of how her character played out if
you're familiar with with marvel bare
with me for a second classic Nick Fury
which is to say the white guy Nick Fury
that version of his character always had
safeguards always had bunkers he always
had these these situations in place so
that if everything went to pot there was
some place he could retreat to and then
tried to defeat whatever that enemy was
but the fact remains that in this
instance Maria Hill following the rise
of Captain America Steve Rogers
conquering the entirety of the United
States when underground and what she did
is she became an information broker for
the various renegade superheroes out
there who were trying to find ways to
topple Captain America the Hydra agent
all she did was slip them information
whatever information she could get now
of course that information came from
various sources she had who had been
captured by Hydra in the sense that they
were former shield agents former
superheroes they would pass information
onto her for the greater good which in
turn she would pass on to Iron Man and
his forces now what this does is it
brings the role of Maria Hill into sharp
relief in the sense that she basically
finds a black out
now of course black out being the person
that basically grabbed New York and
threw it in the dark force energy is the
only guy who can
basically bringing out the problem with
this is that his allegiances are still a
little off the idea is that with him
working alongside Captain America he
didn't know where this would lead to and
so the result is that once Captain
America used the powers of black out and
then took over the country black out had
regrets black out wasn't sure that he
had done the right thing but the problem
is that black out was never an a-list
villain he was never kingpin he was
never a Doctor Octopus he was never you
know any of these characters who's just
like I know what I stand for I know
exactly what I believe he was a guy that
at the first sign of danger would run
for the hills and so it was easier for
him to basically pretend to continue
being an ally of Hydra and so in the
face of all this Maria hill does the
only thing she can do she shoots him in
the back of the head and kills him and
in doing so the spell is broken
New York is free out to the world which
in turn freeze all of New York
superheroes into the fray it starts
bringing in dr. strange Iron Fist Power
Man cloak-and-dagger all these
superheroes no matter how popular no
matter how minor are all now returning
and so again this basically continues us
at the stage before the defeat of Hydra
and so what happens here is that in this
moment we also remember have to deal
with the Chitauri now for those of you
guys who don't know who haven't been
keeping up that was the way in which
Hydra Captain America constantly kept a
low flight on edge it was one thing for
them to be stuck outside the planet
Earth because of the huge shield but
what Hydra Captain America had done is
he has also gone to this jet re race
stolen one of their Queens and brought
them back to earth and then for that
reason the Chitauri were constantly
trying to invade the earth
you know crashing themselves on the
shield and alpha flight was constantly
trying to stop the dattari army the
result is that the Chitauri were
basically continuing to go against Alpha
Flight it was battling 24 hours a day
day after day and they would just send
wave after wave after wave after wave
which would increase a number with each
wave and so again it was just hordes
just bombarding on earth now one could
ask the question why didn't alpha fly
just stand out of the way and just let
the Chitauri just keep invading earth
you know just keep smashing into the
shield
well the issue with that is they didn't
know how well the shield was sustained
their protectors of earth despite the
fact that they were cast out from the
planet they exist to keep it safe at the
same time it was also a way to draw a
little bit of a little bit of tension in
the story it was a way for next measure
to just say
oh man look at how he's also they are
look at how worn out they are you know
that kind of thing now with the earth
superheroes basically returning with
black panther in Wakanda for example
having been captured for the most part
everybody else staves off as best they
can they defeat every single one of
these Hydra agents or at least attempt
to as best they can and so what this
does is us leading into a crescendo is
leading into this final moment this
final push when everything that Hydra
built is gonna come crashing down but
the question also has to be asked what
about classic Captain America one of the
biggest questions that I've been seeing
down in the comments section is what is
this vanishing point again for those of
you guys who are not keeping up with
secret Empire what we've gotten at well
at least we got at the end of like the
second or third issue and then we've
gotten an interspersed in the different
story so far is someplace that we only
know as the vanishing point and within
this vanishing point is classic Captain
America which is to say Steve Rogers
before he was revealed to be a Hydra
agent classic Steve Rogers so the good
guy the issue is we didn't know what
this was we had no clue what this place
was all we knew is that this was a guy
just wandering around but we had no clue
what in the world was going on he's had
little glimpses where he's basically
recalled his own history his origin
story being a byproduct of the super
soldier program fighting against the
Nazis during World War two Bucky Barnes
dying against the drone playing all
these different things this intact
history that we know so well all of this
is basically coming out of this
vanishing point and so in this moment
when he sees what seems to be Sharon
Carter the sort of ghostly apparition
when he calls out to her when she
basically vanishes what we're told is
that everyone's gone everybody that
Steve Rogers had met up to this point in
the vanishing point is gone they're not
there anymore and the reason why is
because this vanishing point basically
seems to be the Cosmic Cube that this
vanishing point is Kovac herself that
she's the one that made all this stuff
the way it is
which begs the question how does this
reconcile these two Captain America's
how does it reconcile the Hydra Captain
America in the real world and this
classic Captain America in this
vanishing point presumably inside the
Cosmic Cube and I can tell you right now
the next video that we do will answer
that man it will answer all your burning
questions it will
yeah it's pretty awesome it's pretty
exciting ah man because like after the
next issue I look at that and I was like
well I know exactly how this story is
gonna end and uh and it's gonna be
amazing
members of the Rob core man I am so sad
that secret Empire is coming to an end
I've loved this story so far it's it's
it's so cool I mean I've been reading
comics since like 1994 90 95 something
like that maybe a little bit earlier so
it's all just kind of a give-and-take I
mean everybody who was reading this knew
that like the original Captain America
was gonna come back but it's kind of a
cool thing with this whole secret Empire
story because this is to me one of the
greatest stories involving Captain
America and evil Captain America it's
always something that I thought was
interesting because it's something that
we've never really seen before when it
came to Captain America's character on
the whole he was usually always the good
guy he was like Superman right like with
the exception of injustice you never
really saw an evil Superman with Captain
America is much the same way he was
always a good guy his personality was
switched from time to time but that was
about it it was always like a one-off or
something along those lines or someone
impersonating Captain America so that's
why this is so cool but in the last
video we had talked about how the fall
of Hydra was basically beginning about
how there were a litany of things that
were all taking place all at the same
time the character quasar who had
previously been incapacitated at the
start of secret Empire had been left
unconscious the entire time we had
talked about how in Fantastic Four
volume 1 issue number 522 quasar was
able to go toe-to-toe with Galactus and
so because of that NYX pincer drawing on
all that storytelling for Marvel
basically established quasar is the one
character who could take down the shield
this massive force field that it
surrounded earth and kept some of the
most powerful superheroes outside earth
and forced them to basically fight
against this horde of Chitauri army you
know over and over and over again but
the idea was that with quasar
effectively channeling this brief
glimpse of the power of Galactus through
the quantum bands it resulted in the
shield being taken down this resulted in
the various superheroes who were
stranded outside earth Carol Danvers
Hyperion these characters just came
flowing back in and they were able to
help turn the tide of battle now the
other thing we had talked about is
something called
the vanishing point and the vanishing
point was very much this obscure thing
that we didn't really know anything
about all we knew is that there was a
guy who was running around there saying
that he was Steve Rogers
and by all spinners of measurement he
was the classic Steve Rogers which is to
say the version of Captain America that
we saw before the events of secret
Empire before he was turned into a Hydra
agent during Avengers standoff during
this time we also ended up finding out
that cobb 'ok the sentient Cosmic Cube
was present as well and so what this
does is answer that question so for
those of you guys who feel a little
confused about what's taking place with
this whole vanishing point thing this
will answer all of that essentially with
Steve Rogers following kamek down this
you know rabbit hole so to speak
effectively what this is is a huge
explanation on what the vanishing point
is itself in truth the vanishing point
is just a place created by the Cosmic
Cube topic and simply houses memories
that's all it is this version of Steve
Rogers is a memory of who Captain
America used to be as opposed to who he
is now and that makes sense because
remember comics a little kid and like
every little kid comic sees the world
through idealized eyes which is to say
here's how I would like the world to be
not the way the world is but the idea
here is that with copic as a character
when she looked to Captain America and
when the Red Skull had basically asked
her to change the history of Captain
America and to make him into a Hydra
agent she did so through the eyes of a
child believing that she was genuinely
making the world a better place the
problem with this is that when her
essence was quote-unquote fragmented and
scattered throughout the world her mind
remained and watching the events unfold
watching the whole of secret Empire take
place
she basically come to the realization
that she believed she made a mistake but
with regards to the remainder of the
earth superheroes remember under the
rallying point of Sam Wilson who had
returned to his mantle as Captain
America following the events of secret
Empire basically the time where he quit
this gave us superheroes a rallying
point because of this it coincides with
the capture of T'Challa now keep in mind
with Black Panther ruling over what
Conda historically speaking in Marvel
Comics what khand has always been
isolated and this has been just as much
a position of black panther in order to
maintain his resources as it is the
traditional role of the Black Panther
lineage remember when it comes to the
origin of the whole Black Panther clan
the idea was that this giant meteor
containing vibranium just crash-landed
in Wakanda the result is that vishing
guy who I believe was the original black
panther basically prayed to the Panther
God bast in order to protect the mound
bast gave them the abilities to do it
and turn what Conda was built around
what's known as the great mound for this
giant store of vibranium and every
single black panther that's ever existed
has served the purpose of making sure
that the great mound is always protected
with T'Challa and with two challahs
father they looked at it as a measure of
resources if vibranium is one of the
most important metals in existence
people will pay a massive amount of
money for it and so this became as much
of a tool to bolster the various
resources of Wakanda making it the most
technologically advanced country in the
world this is how all that worked but
because of all that Black Panther has
routinely been isolated and so during
the events of secret Empire when the
Cosmic Cube fragmented and just split
all across the world
Black Panther gained one of the shards
but instead of just immediately running
to Captain America and say haha look
what I have you'll never get it instead
he just stayed in Wakanda and Captain
America SandForce after force after
force to try to capture the Cosmic Cube
shard from black panther himself and
none of it was ever successful the
result is that ultimately it took Baron
Zemo Captain America's second in command
with an army far larger than the
wakandans could possibly withstand to
finally invade the territory take the
Cosmic Cube fragment and bring Black
Panther in as a prisoner so that's where
all this basically begins to come into
play now the other half of this are the
mutants and that's why a lot of these
tie-ins were really kind of important
when it came to secret empire the
mutants were by and large just out there
by themselves they were in a realm
called Newton and there was basically a
3d of sorts that was struck between
Hydra and the x-men themselves now the
funny thing about this is that this
actually ties into the Captain America a
tie-in for secret Empire itself and it's
actually a cool scenario because what it
does is it deals with the character of
Sally Floyd now of course Sally Floyd is
most notable as being a really funny her
claim to fame and the Civil War
frontline stories but she was basically
a reporter then at the end of it all sat
down and asked Captain America you were
talking about fighting on behalf of
freedom and you willingly sacrifice
other superheroes lives and once it was
all said and done we're right back where
we were before so what progress did you
really make and so because of all that
because those hard-hitting hardline
questions were being asked ultimately
Sally Floyd kind of gained a reputation
as being a person that asks the wrong
kind of question
to the wrong kinds of people now as a
journalist that's fine because her goal
was to uncover the absolute truth but in
the Captain America tie-in she was told
do not ask about the destruction of Las
Vegas she instead chose to do that and
of course as I've always said you have
the right to say anything you want to
and you also have the right to deal with
the consequences of it the result is its
ally Floyd was thrown in prison now
during this whole questioning process
she had basically asked about the ex
about the idea that the xmin are
receiving preferential treatment now the
official answer of Captain America as
head of Hydra was that well know the
x-men are kind of out there we view them
just like anybody else they exist within
the continental United States and so
they are under hydras rule the truth was
that he had struck a back-alley deal
with magneto basically saying hey look
you stay away I stay away and we're all
gonna be fine now this makes perfect
sense just because it's the x-men
there's some of the most powerful beings
in existence Emma Frost by herself could
probably take out Captain America and
all of his Hydra forces all these
members of the x-men could easily band
together and take on Captain America to
say nothing of magneto and that's the
importance of all this while all these
superheroes are out fighting while
spider-man had successfully dealt with
the new superior spider-man with the
return of Doctor Octopus this ultimately
reveals the idea that Captain America in
his treaty with magneto had basically
expected the x-men to hand over the
shard of the Cosmic Cube if they ever
came into possession of it the fact that
they didn't put Captain America in a
situation where he basically said you
are now an enemy of Hydra now the funny
thing about this is that he says hey
look I'm willing to let bygones be
bygones if you give me the shard of the
Cosmic Cube the result is that the x-men
were biding their time they were just
waiting for the chance to strike and
that's the importance of all this is
because the x-men have always been
viewed as outliers the result is that
when the x-men have the opportunity to
basically fight alongside all these
other other superheroes and essentially
say hey look we're not as much of an
outlier as you think we are they jump on
that opportunity that result is that
while Emma Frost was basically dealing
with this whole thing with Captain
America she served as a distraction the
reason why is because Captain America is
floating around in a giant ship and that
giant ship is made of metal and Magneto
controls metal and with the force of God
he brings the
thing crashing down also keep in mind
here we have Odin son with the Jason
Aaron run of thor odin's son was unable
to wield his hammer because he didn't
believe that he was worthy of wielding
his hammer case in point a lot of people
talk about the struggles of trials and
tribulations that Odin's son went
through to be able to lift his hammer he
went through all these things he's you
know hundreds if not thousands of years
of you know trials and tests and so on
and so forth and a 12 issued limited
story that was published in 2006 2007 it
was after the events of thor ragnarok
that detailed the origin story of how
thor was basically able to wield his
hammer in the first place remember how
it was if Thor became worthy was never
explored in Marvel Comics all we knew is
that he had been sent to earth and
forced into the body of Donald Blake in
order to experience humbleness so he
would wield his hammer as a hero as
opposed to this bloodlust it warrior who
just wanted to get in fights all the
time like a child effectively the result
was that he gained some measure of
humbleness he went back to wielding his
hammer again and that was it that was
his origin story and it happened in one
comic in the 12 issue limited series
that revealed that he originally became
worthy because Odin sent Loki and SIF
and Odin's son on a mission to fight a
dragon they succeeded and he picked up
his hammer now force with this in mind
because Odin his son's loyalty is to the
site of good at the end he abandons the
whole idea that he doesn't believe he's
worthy to wield his hammer and instead
literally turns against all the forces
of Hydra the result of this is that he
helps to turn the tide now at the same
time we get a little bit of humor in
this story with the champions remember
they're teenagers that's really all they
are and at the end of the day they were
basically being held prisoner by
taskmaster and Black Ant now these guys
were never really important they were
basically the comedic relief for the
entire secret Empire event which was
kind of interesting but the idea is that
with the tide being turned with Thor you
know they they make this comment about
all men did you hear that boom it's like
yep that's the we're gonna lose boom and
so of course they turncoat on Hydra and
they basically tell the champions hey
look guys when the Avengers come make
sure they know that we let you watch TV
and that we got you milkshakes after you
cleaned your bunks now when I was
reading that I couldn't help but think
that like taskmaster in Black Ant were
like hey look guys you got to clean your
bunks I'll tell you what if you clean
them we'll take you to Shake Shack and
we'll be
stuff in there and the champions like
yeah man I really hope that's how the
whole event played out but regardless of
course the champions are basically
released by taskmaster and black ant
which bolsters the existing ranks of the
superheroes fighting against Hydra and
that's basically what this says that's
why in so many ways and so many times
I've said this is what civil war two
should have been there's motivation
there's Drive there's logic and reason
behind why it is the superhero community
is fighting one another and civil war -
it was just weld as inhuman says you can
see the future so we're just gonna take
it as an absolute truth why well because
the movies coming out soon and we got to
have a story called Civil War the idea
was with secret Empire is there fighting
against what they believe to be an
oppressive regime the idea that Hydra
Captain America says he's gonna change
the world
when in reality they see that he's
making it worse now the question has to
be asked here how many lives are being
lost in this battle how many buildings
are being destroyed how many people are
losing their homes losing their
belongings are their personal things do
the ends justify the means the idea is
that again this is really more of just
setting the stage for this final battle
in the sense that dr. strange basically
brings back Jane Foster Thor because
remember in that the Free Comic Book Day
issue of secret Empire one of the things
that cthe own who was possessing the
body of Scarlet Witch did was banished
Jane Foster Thor to another dimension
another thing that goes on here is the
idea that when it comes to Sharon Carter
she's continually being brainwashed by
dr. Fausta's that's why these little
tidbits that's why these little things
are so cool remember when it came to
Sharon Carter she was a longtime love
interest of Captain America but when he
revealed himself to be a Hydra agent she
basically ran off he was like okay look
you are not the person that I love don't
want to have anything to do with you but
it's not like Nick Spencer sat down and
said you know what would be cool is if a
guy named dr. Foster's who is really
good at brainwashing people brainwash
you and Carter just for the sake of
historic this all goes back to civil war
during that whole thing that dealt with
that original Civil War story the whole
thing that dealt with the first death of
Captain America Sharon Carter was the
one who pulled the trigger what we ended
up learning was that the Red Skull had
wanted to simply eliminate Captain
America and the whole Civil War event
allowed for him to operate under the
current because all the superheroes were
distracted with their own inner
conflicts the result is that he
basically grabbed dr.
fastest and then brainwashed Sharon
Carter but we didn't know that all we
knew is that when Civil War was over
Captain America was being taken for his
trial he was shot in the shoulder by
crossbones and everybody believed that
he did that crossbones had fired a
couple more shots and it ultimately
killed Captain America in truth dr.
Fausta's had brainwashed Sharon Carter
so that when crossbones
shot Captain America it was a
distraction everybody started looking
away they started running they started
panicking and in the panic and the
turmoil Sharon Carter fired a couple
shots into the stomach of Captain
America and was the one that actually
killed him now of course in response to
this and the reason why this is
important is because following this
event and Sharon Carter learning that
she'd been brainwashed and she was the
one that shot cap
she began to basically listen to the
voice of dr. Foster's over and over and
over again and build up a tolerance to
his brainwashing techniques the result
is that while he's trying to force her
to basically hail Hydra she plays along
biding her time waiting until the point
where the superhero strike she grabs
that as the opportunity to take out dr.
Foster's and begin operating on her side
of the spectrum trying to help bring
down Hydra and so what is up happening
here is that with this Cosmic Cube being
incomplete which is to say one of the
shards is still missing one is up
happening is Captain America Don's a
suit of armor and with the superheroes
facing off against the forces of Hydra
with them effectively winning all hope
seems to be completely lost when Hydra
Captain America emerges from the capital
building with a suit of armor powered by
the Cosmic Cube meaning he has all the
powers of the cube itself he's basically
God man is you guys really think I was
gonna make you guys wait a week did you
really think I was gonna make you wait a
week for the end of secret Empire no not
at all we're doing this injustice style
hopefully you guys are excited anyway so
this is the conclusion this is the end
of secret Empire now the cool thing
about this is that secret Empire at
least in my opinion is one of the
coolest stories about Captain America I
mean I get that there are some people
out there who are just like no my
opinion isn't absolute I don't like it
no one should like it because I don't
like it that's fun I mean I think it's a
really cool story but the idea here is
that with with you know the the Hydra
Captain America with secret Empire it's
not suddenly an all-new all-different
marvel thing it is to a degree but it's
actually been one cohesive story that's
been going all the way back to castaway
and dimension Z and that's why I like it
is because
just one great big huge tale of Steve
Rogers as a character which is why I say
it's so cool is because we've we've read
a million stories where Captain America
has led the Avengers into you know into
a conflict against a million enemies
we've seen that a million times before
thoroughness yield find the bad guys if
they become rinse and repeat stories and
so the idea was secret Empire was to
switch all that up to stop doing the
same rinse and repeat stories all the
time to give us like a darker character
what would happen if Captain America
Steve Rogers became a bad guy and so
what this does at least you know with
the whole iron male cast away in
dimension Z that all went all the way
back to the whole idea of Steve Rogers
losing a Super Soldier Serum that's
really all it was when he lost his Super
Soldier Serum he was basically aged up
he began to age extremely fast and so
what ended up happening is he basically
handed his mantle over to Sam Wilson now
of course Sam Wilson have been the
sidekick for quite some time and so it
made sense that if anybody was going to
be the next version of Captain America
it would be Sam Wilson because he's
fought alongside him so much longer
because of this when all-new
all-different marvel started with Steve
Rogers still being an older guy what
ended up happening is there was an event
that was written called Avengers
standoff and what Avengers standoff did
is it basically brought in the idea that
shield had basically recreated a
reconstructed a cosmic cube using
various shards that had existed all
throughout its history and so on and so
forth and then when they reconstructed
this cosmic cube they basically created
this sort of fake paradise there are
more or less warped reality to
essentially take over the lives of
villains which is to say blind them from
what was really going on it was a very
matrix esque
kind of situation the result here was
that when the Avengers learned about
what was going on it was considered a
violation of human rights and so as we
would expect the Avengers responded the
Avengers basically took down the
entirety of Pleasant Hill you know the
whole assault on Pleasant Hills
storyline so on and so forth but in the
midst of all this the Red Skull had
become aware of the fact that the Cosmic
Cube had become sentient but the idea
here is that with shield being brought
down with Red Skull learning that the
Cosmic Cube was sentient Red Skull in
turn used the Cosmic Cube to simply sit
down to say okay fine if I've never been
able to beat Steve Rogers fighting him
hand-to-hand then I'll just alter his
past and I'll just make him a Hydra
agent using the Cosmic Cube and that's
exactly what happened now this
eventually led to a rift between Steve
Rogers as a Hydra agent and [ __ ]
because you know Steve Rogers said red
school is not really Hydra he's just
pretending to be Hydra ultimately
killing the red skull taking over Hydra
himself and then launching this campaign
to take over the entirety of North
America with his sights set on the world
now the other half of this is we picked
up with something called the vanishing
point and we didn't really know what the
vanishing point was all we knew is that
the classic Steve Rogers which is to say
the version that existed before secret
empire which is running around this
vanishing point now eventually we learn
the vanishing point was just the mind of
cause of copic the Cosmic Cube it was
basically this classic Steve Rogers
being a memory of who he used to be and
so again it essentially kept the concept
of him alive even if he wasn't alive in
the traditional sense now what this does
is with that kind of catching us up to a
degree again you know you can go check
out the most recent video to fully
understand what's going on with this
basically boiling down to the entirety
of the earth superheroes taking on the
Hydra Captain America they all do the
best they can but keep in mind he's
captured all but one shard of the Cosmic
Cube so even if he doesn't necessarily
have the power to warp all things in
existence he's got more than enough
power to take on the various superheroes
and that's exactly what he does he
basically shows up and begins taking
them all down now of course this
coincides with Sam Wilson handing over
his shard of the Cosmic Cube basically
giving up basically saying hey look you
know here here's your shard do whatever
it is that you want to do now in this
moment this is where all the superheroes
lose suddenly Captain America uses the
Cosmic Cube and whisks them all away and
that's par for the course when it comes
to all these cosmic stories whether it's
the original secret wars secret Wars -
and the Beyonder came to earth when it
comes to the Infinity Gauntlet infinity
war in affinity crusade infinity abyss
when it comes to all those stories it's
always just some being with godlike
power wipes every body from existence so
it's not new that's routine that always
happens it's one of the big complaints
that people have when it comes to those
characters when it comes to those
massive story arcs what do you do when
you're facing a foe who's virtually
indestructible now of course this
basically leads to this sort of
recreation of earth as Hydra Captain
America wants it to be in this instance
Doctor Doom leads the Fantastic Four
instead of Reed Richards Professor
Xavier and Magneto are considered mutant
revolutionaries and they're executed by
high
but suddenly all these issues that that
Hydra Captain America sees begin to get
whisked away they begin to go away they
begin to vanish and so with this virtual
you know godlike power that's possessed
by Hydra Captain America with Sam Wilson
again popping up on the scene saying hey
look here's my final shard all these
things taking place what we end up
finding out is that this was all
basically a ruse by the superhero
community that they realized that it'd
be almost impossible for them to
directly stop Hydra Captain America what
they needed was someone who would
basically be able to offer them a
counterpoint but what we end up finding
out here is that with Bucky Barnes
having previously been inside the
vanishing point you know with him
knowing that the memory quote-unquote of
the classic Steve Rogers is there what
he basically does is initiate this sort
of rescue mission where he literally
shows up inside of the vanishing point
and then just tries to grab Steve Rogers
classic Steve Rogers and bring him back
now the other half of this is the
character of kaabah curse elf the cool
thing about Kovac as a character is that
again with a cosmic cube that she comes
from having been so newly created the
fact that she's a little girl is
designed to mimic her stage that is to
say how old she is
as far as the cosmic humans meaning the
Cosmic Cube is like in its adolescence
so to speak but with the whole character
of copic she's terrified of everything
that's going on because remember she
does not see herself as this
all-powerful
godly entity she sees herself as a kid
who could just do some pretty crazy
things and so at the end of the day she
doesn't have the full wherewithal of her
powers more so than that because she
sees the world as someone who's just
basically scared of what's going on not
fully understanding or regretting her
decisions she in turn tries to run away
now this is why classic Captain America
is so important and this is why people
love to classic Captain America will get
a little more into this you know classic
versus Hydra
you know Steve Rogers I here in a minute
but with classic Steve Rogers he was a
rallying point he was a point by which
despite the fact that you could shoot
him with a gun because that's how he
died despite the fact that you could
knock him out he was a guy that
everybody implicitly trusted he was
first in last out always the guy to be
there to make sure that things ran like
they were supposed to the result was
that people would just follow him no
matter where it was that he would go or
what it was that he wanted to do and
this was basically the scheme that was
pulled with this cosmic hue more or less
be
reinstated it's basically Hydra Captain
America using the power of Quebec
because she was too afraid to use it on
her own
what is up happening is that with Bucky
Barnes going into the vanishing point
basically into the mind of topic
retrieving her alongside classic Steve
Rogers she basically takes her power
back and everything starts to return the
normal and that's when we get into this
battle of classic Captain America versus
Hydra Captain America and that's the
cool thing here these characters are
able to exist simultaneously because
once a memory and one is not if we had
to sit down and we had to say okay if
we're basing this you know on like the
physical form right like the physical
body which one's the real Captain
America that is Hydra cat this is the
same Captain America we've been seen for
years and years and years just with us
on with his history alter the classic
Captain America that you're seeing right
now with the blue outfit and the a on
his hand all that kind of stuff he's
basically a memory given physical form
and so it's essentially a resurrection
of source now of course the with this
fight between the two of them it is the
quintessential battle of like freedom
versus security that's really what this
is designed to represent because the
whole story was basically predicated on
that it was the story that created this
kind of argument that really hailed to
that bet phrase that's overused you know
those who would sacrifice freedom for
security blah blah blah you know if that
whole argument come to bear in this
story because the nature of this is that
these guys both represent two separate
sides both of which are valid if you
guys are familiar myself a nautical
candy and a college story and run a
channel called eligible monster where we
talk about games and do all kinds of
cool stuff one of the discussions that
we had recently was we ran over who was
right and injustice was it was a
Superman was a Batman you know Superman
basically wanted to rule the world
through control but he basically became
a dictator
Batman was the guy who was fighting
against him as the rebel in this story
it's much the same way Hydra Steve
Rogers wants to rule the world with
absolute control classic Steve Rogers
says no people need to choose but notice
this both sides are legitimate say for
example that they're you're walking down
an alley and there's a little girl you
know and her parents have just been
killed by a mugger
you don't catch the mugger the mugger
runs off the little girls crying are you
really gonna walk up to her and say look
I know we probably could have prevented
this from happening but you losing your
parents is the price you pay for freedom
because the alternative is that we try
to
I'm everywhere and we restrict people's
rights and things like that are you
gonna be the one to tell that little
girl that well of course not but at the
same time freedom is a necessity and
that's why both these things are so
important is because there's a balancing
act you can't have one in the extreme
you can't have extreme freedom you can't
have you can't have a society where it's
just hey do whatever you want to
whatever happens happens but you also
can't have a society where you say
nobody can do anything without my
permission first because at that point
things go absolutely Iran you have to
have this middle ground people can do
things but there have to be consequences
for law and order has to exist checks
and balances have to exist people can
commit crimes but there has to be
punishment for those crimes
you know there's imperfections all
throughout the system as it exists but
you try to make it work as best you can
and ultimately that's the argument
classic Captain America has and that's
why people love him so much is because
at the end of the day he says look
things are screwed up things aren't
necessarily right but in the end the
freedom that we enjoy gives us the
freedom to choose it gives us the
freedom to say what if we don't like the
direction that things are going in what
if we don't like where we are right now
then let's change it because if you walk
up to a person and you say change your
life and you put a gun in their face
they'll change their life until that gun
goes away and then once the guns gone
they'll go right back to where they were
before true change has to happen
organically people have to change
because it's fear of where they used to
be versus where they could be that
drives them to keep doing better and
that's the goal of classic Captain
America is look we've made all kinds of
mistakes war disease famine we've done
all kinds of terrible things but we can
learn from them we can look at where we
used to be and say why we want to go
back to that let's go to this let's look
to the brighter future and let's do that
instead Hydra Captain America had a
similar view his idea was to do it at
the barrel of a gun now at the end of
the day it also raises the question if
the ultimate goal is achieved enough
what difference is there and if these
people cared about their freedom so much
then why weren't they fighting for it
and so that really brings out that whole
thing into play raised that whole
question and well you know you can't
stick your head in the sand hoping
things will get better and they complain
when they don't doing things changes
things doing nothing keeps things
exactly as they are and so because of
that in this moment when we basically
have this question of who's the correct
person here Hydra Captain America does
the only thing that he can do grabs
hammer of four in an attempt to lift it
up and prove his worth only to find out
that he can't that he's not worthy
because he no longer believes he is he's
no longer righteous he's no longer the
right guy here now of course this leads
to classic Captain America picking up
the hammer of fork now this is not the
first time we've seen this but it's
always one of those cool things and
that's why people say well the fact that
he's picked it up so often the fact that
so many people have lifted the hammer
for it doesn't really even matter
anymore
that's nonsense that's that's absolute
that's absolutely tomfoolery it is the
context of when the Hammers picked up
that makes it matter in 50 years we can
have stories where a thousand people
lifted the hammer of Thor but the
context in which the Hammers picked up
is what makes it important because this
provides a kind of finality it provides
an answer to that question no classic
Captain America's right no Hydra Captain
America is wrong that's the end of that
there's no discussion there's no debate
none of that stuff this is how it is and
that's what makes it so cool is because
it's almost like this this sort of you
know Mike drop right there's like boom I
hit you with the hammer of Thor Mike
drop like it's one of those really
really cool moments it's one of those
cool things well what is it happening
here as things wrap up relatively fast I
mean it basically turns into a
rebuilding phase but one thing to keep
in mind is that despite the fact that
things have changed one thing that that
classic Captain America did not have
copic do is wipe the minds of the whole
of humanity it's important that the
whole of humanity remember though look
at superheroes with a skewed perspective
they look at superheroes and they won't
necessarily trust them again but at the
end of the day they will know that the
superheroes did right by and the
superheroes didn't change anything
trying to make things better again okay
so we are getting into the aftermath of
secret Empire and god I'm going into the
weekend I'm loafing this weekend I am I
am not really gonna do anything if it
doesn't require me to I'm gonna watch
Netflix I'm gonna clean up my house I'm
gonna have a good weekend I don't know
maybe he like took some really nice
dinners or something like that but
secret Empire admittedly has been one of
the most divisive stories that I've ever
read in the history of comics I mean I
was there when like the Clone Saga was
Spider Man but I was there when that
whole thing happened and like it was
interesting to see but it was really
more of like fans of Spider Man it
wasn't like a split in the Marvel
community and it's been nuts too
this whole thing unfold but whenever we
would do character explanations and we
would talk about stories that would
split the Marvel community you guys are
living through this in real time now
people are more vocal now than they've
ever been because they have Twitter and
Facebook and YouTube channels like mine
and so on and so forth but the idea here
is that this story just really created a
rift in the community and it was crazy
but if you if you not had a chance to
see my secret empire videos I highly
recommend that you go check them out
just for the sake of understanding
everything that's going on but the idea
shield had created a cosmic cube the
Cosmic Cube had become sentient and the
result was that the Cosmic Cube was
taken over by the Red Skull and it was
taught to believe in hydras ideologies
in response to this at the request of
the Red Skull the Cosmic Cube altered
though the reality of Captain America
Steve Rogers it altered its past - in
order to make it out the Steve Rogers
was a Hydra agent and so with this
altered reality what Steve Rogers began
to do was go through and basically
implement his plan to allow Hydra to
take over the United States setting his
sights on the world and then using the
Cosmic Cube to take over the entire
universe now of course this led to this
hunt for the Cosmic Cube in the sense of
the cubed basically been shattered and
it was literally just this chase to find
all these different shards but what
Marvel also gave us was an out they gave
us something called the vanishing point
and what we ended up learning was that
with the Cosmic Cube becoming sentient
it also became terrified of what the
world was like with Hydra ruling it and
so what the Cosmic Cube did is a created
the vanishing point as a place where the
memory of these various superheroes
specifically Captain America with how he
used to be was basically held and so
what ended up happening is that at the
end of secret Empire this memory was
given a physical body and this basically
was the return of classic Captain
America and so classic Captain America
fought against Hydra Captain America and
the classic version won and so in the
aftermath of this this story picks up
with essentially what amounts to a
healing process the idea that the world
is rebuilding but the coolest thing
about this is that this focuses on the
question who was right in secret Empire
and how did things transpire did they
transpire the way that we think they did
or daar we not remembering it correctly
and that's the crazy thing because there
is this prison that was created within
the realm of the
the marvel universe Lisa's prison as is
called the shadow pillar now shadow
pillar basically seems to be the
Florence Colorado Supermax now for those
of you guys who don't know here in the
real world Florence Colorado is home to
a supermax prison where people spend 23
hours out of the day in solitary
confinement they get one hour to
basically go out and and do their own
thing but it's housed the most violent
individuals in the world like Timothy
McVeigh for example after blowing the
Federal Building in half at Oklahoma
City he was housed in Florence Colorado
until he was executed so again there's
all these different things you know with
regards to the comparisons between
Marvel and the real world but there's
only one occupant of the shadow pillar
prison and that's Hydra Captain America
now of course the classic version goes
to see him and this is probably one of
the greatest conversations in the
history of Marvel Comics it's so cool
the way this unfolds because it's the
question who was really right here now
the funny thing is that witness
conversation initially opens this really
just Hydra cap saying I know why you're
here like you're here for maybe some
kind of indication you're here to
basically say hey look you know yeah man
I was right you were wrong but the funny
thing about this is that Hydra cap makes
the point in basically saying I didn't
break any laws I didn't do anything
illegal and that's the funny thing about
this is because remember when he rose to
power it's not like he walked in to the
United States with an army of Hydra
agents assassinated the president wiped
out Congress destroyed the preme Court
it wasn't a Handmaid's Tale and the rise
of the sons of jacob it was him coming
in and actually being given that power
and with that absolute authority he
conquered the United States he was asked
to be director of shield he was given
the position given that power by an
external source he never actually
conquered anyone he never actually
killed anyone in terms of you know his
role or as his rise to power and that's
what makes this so cool
is because in the face of this classic
Captain America says well we'll end up
finding you accountable anyway and Hydra
Captain America's response is yeah
because I'm not a friend and this is
really cool because myself and comic
story and we're talking about this and
he's starting a secret a secret Empire
coverage and you guys should definitely
check it out but we were running them
we're running over this whole thing and
that's the crazy thing about it is
because Hydra Captain America is not
wrong if we look at the various
characters who have gone through and who
have engaged in actions that have
resulted in the loss of life you have
characters like magneto who stood trial
for his actions but Magneto
and an Avenger The Scarlet Witch
Quicksilver they were both Avengers
they've done some pretty heinous things
and they were never held accountable
Captain America is one of these guys who
protects his own and that's the reason
why this is such a great big huge debate
is because the whole argument the whole
point that Hydra Captain America makes
here is you're a guy who protects the
people that you agree with you protect
the people that you like you don't
protect the people that you don't like
not only that it's also this equation
being dragged in of what's the world
like now is the world really a better
place because in this instance what
Hydra Captain America says is look I was
literally trying to make the world
better I saw this perfect world where
there was no war I saw this perfect
world where there was no panic there was
no chaos there was no famine there were
no snow children starving in the streets
there were no people robbing banks in
order to make sure they could provide
their own that none of that stuff was
there I saw a perfect world and then you
came along and you took it you took it
away and you basically returned the
world back to the way that it used to be
and what he ends up saying is you may
believe that you've won but you haven't
won because Hydra had this perfect world
for a brief moment in time those who
were loyal to Hydra saw this perfect
reality and the result is that when you
took it away they are now all the more
desperate it's tantamount to going to a
starving man giving him a sandwich
letting him have one bite and then
taking the sandwich away he'll do almost
anything to get it back in order to
satiate that hunger that's aching him so
bad and so they also an argument here is
that Hydra is gonna be more desperate
now than they've ever been
because they want that world that they
saw for a brief glimpse in time now what
this also does that transitions for
second two characters like The Punisher
and it's kind of cool here because with
the Punisher because of the fact that he
basically says look I followed Hydra
Captain America because he was Captain
America then once it was revealed that
Hydra Captain America was basically a
bad guy that Punisher basically sort of
turncoat it ended up going back to his
normal way and just killing everybody
who is Hydra but that's the funny thing
about this is because until classic
Captain America showed up there was no
reason for Punisher to believe that
Hydra Captain America and classic
Captain America were two different
people now remember this is not new and
the original Civil War story one of the
things that Marvel solidified is that
Frank Castle fought in the Vietnam War
because he wanted to be like Captain
America Frank Castle Idol
Captain America and so because of that
whatever Captain America does Frank
hassel will go along with it and so
again it's really a funny situation
because one of the things that I noticed
with regards to the comments on secret
Empire is a lot of people were like no
way vana sure would join Hydra Captain
America but he would because the actions
of Hydra Captain America fall perfectly
in line with what Frank Castle does
Frank Castle doesn't go around to like
food banks and like donate money he just
goes around and kills criminals wherever
he finds them so he really is in a lot
of ways exactly what it was that Hydra
was fighting for at the time the other
half of this is the question of did
classic Steve Rogers make the world
better by setting things the way they
used to be under the rule of Hydra sure
superheroes were killed and sure
Inhumans were basically tossed in camps
but people were not afraid of their
neighbors people could leave their doors
unlocked at night because they knew that
everybody was too scared to break into
their homes
nobody committed any crimes whatsoever
because the hammer of Hydra came down
fast and it came down Swift and so
because of this with classic Steve
Rogers setting things back to the way
they used to be now people go back to
being scared again
people go back to being fearful of their
neighbors where people didn't have
poverty where we didn't have
homelessness because Hydra provided
everybody with everything they needed
well then suddenly people are cast back
down into homelessness people are cast
back down into poverty governmental
corruption will run rampant once again
money will be the defining factor on
what it is that makes a person
worthwhile the world is not better than
it was but notice this this is the exact
same argument that we had when it came
to injustice the question is is it worth
giving up everything is it worth people
basically living in fear of their
government in place of living in fear of
their neighbor is that a sacrifice that
people are willing to make and those are
the opposing dichotomies of these two
guys as they argue as they debate that's
what they're talking about the question
is who came out on top here is the world
a better place because of the fact that
it's the way that it used to be in this
instance Hydra Captain America basically
says at least I was honest about what I
was at least I came forward and said I
am an agent of Hydra at least I came
forward and I launched the entire
campaign and I told people if you commit
crimes you will be dealt with harshly I
was the government operating in order to
ensure a safer and secure America with
classic Captain America
with the Avengers it's not that way
remember that was the whole basis behind
the champions the champions joined up
they they formed their own group because
they were tired of seeing the Avengers
go into local towns go into communities
fight these villains and then just walk
off and say okay everything's cool now
when people were watching their
livelihoods come crashing down when they
were watching the homes they built
destroyed because the Avengers were
going through and fighting villains and
then the Avengers just leave the people
looked to Hydra as an alternative the
people welcomed Hydra because in the
face of the Hydra rule sure it was dark
it was dystopian but it also kept them
safe and secure didn't have to worry
about their homes being destroyed
because the Avengers were fighting some
villain and when the fight was finished
the Avengers just left and at the same
time no one appointed Captain America as
a protector of the country it's not like
the Avengers or a government-sanctioned
superhero team the Avengers just formed
one day people basically be a lot of
them and said yeah sure like we love
them being here we love you know we love
them protecting us but the argument of
Hydra Captain America is what's the
difference between what you did and what
I did because people celebrated me too
people said yeah hydras keeping us
protected the actions of the Avengers
the x-men the maximum security storyline
the onslaught saga all this has
basically been these massive calamities
because superheroes chose that they were
gonna be the protectors and in the
aftermath of these conflicts they dusted
their hands they said yes the good guys
winning they patted themselves on the
back they went to the bar they had a
beer and they thought nothing of the
people who were being affected that was
never their concerned you didn't see the
Avengers rebuilding people's homes you
didn't see the Avengers funding
individual people who lost their
livelihood because the business they
worked out was destroyed during a
conflict you didn't see that and so in
this instance Hydra Captain America says
we're basically the same thing you're
vigilantes you appointed yourselves as
protectors you do whatever you feel you
need to do in order to keep the country
protected you protect your own you
protect Avengers because they're your
friends I do the exact same thing so
what's the difference now the other side
of this argument is classic Captain
America comes along and says because you
imprison innocent people because you
took people who you deemed to be the
enemy and you threw him in jail because
you didn't like what they did you went
through back-alley deals you lied you
were duplicitous you tricked people and
you used my face to do it and that's the
huge crux of this argument when shield
gave Hydra Captain America
absolute power they didn't know they
were giving it to a Hydra agent
otherwise they never would have they
thought they were giving it to classic
Captain America who had fought alongside
the United States for years and years
and years and years that's the
difference here is that yes Hydra
Captain America made the country safer
but at the end of the day he was
sacrificing all the wrong things to do
it the argument the classic Captain
America makes here is the same argument
that I made while after I was done
playing devil's advocate about Batman
but it was the argument that I made
towards the tale into the video which
you can find over a comic story and on
the RMV ii podcast we were arguing
injustice sure the world is imperfect
sure there are terrible things that
happen to good people and there are good
things that happen to bad people the
difference between some totalitarian
fascist regime imposing its own will and
his own order and people who were
allowed to explore their own order and
their own will means that people under
the role of freedom are allowed to get
better they were allowed to look at the
way things used to be and say we don't
want to be there anymore we don't want
to cross that bridge anymore we don't
want to be in a world where we're afraid
of our neighbors we don't want to be in
a world where we have to rob in order to
feed ourselves or our children we want
to live in a world where we don't have
to worry about those kinds of things and
so because of that it's Hydra Captain
America is saying yes you instilled
order but it only would have lasted for
so long you're not going to live forever
and even if you were an enlightened
dictatorship even if you were benign in
terms of how you dealt with the average
person who's to say the next person who
took over your role would be the same
and so the idea here is that in a free
society people have the ability to
better their own lives that's the
importance of it people have the ability
to evolve to grow to eventually move
beyond individual desires and wants and
think about what's best for the society
and that's the argument that classic
Captain America makes and so again we're
not really given a resolution on who's
right or who's wrong we're just kind of
told these are the arguments that are
out there and so what is up happening is
ultimately with the guards showing up
and with Cossack Captain America leaving
we end up finding out that Hydra Captain
America's rut was right when he said
hydras everywhere Hydra will never go
away because we end up finding out that
one of these prison guards is a Hydra
agent when he says hail Hydra indicating
that at some point along the line Hydra
Captain America will probably be let
loose but with that being said guys
we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come as explained and make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become
the Rob port if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]